Wir wollen jetzt blicken auf den europäischen Top-Fußball bei den Männern. Wir blicken heute nach Italien, nach Spanien, nach England und wir tun das mit Christian Bernhard, mit Nies Kan und mit einem neuen Ensemble-Mitglied, möchte ich fast sagen. Chris McCarthy ist mal hier. Wir werden ihn gleich vorstellen nach dem hier.
Und nun im Programm, der Rasenfunk.
Der Blick auf andere Linien. Immer mal wieder denke ich mir bei diesem Intro, es ist einfach zehn Sekunden zu lang, aber das liegt ja an dem schreienden Kommentator, weil es so lustig ist, dass man ihn von Anfang bis Ende im Hintergrund schreien hört. Und er hat einfach nicht aufgehört. Hallo und herzlich willkommen liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Schön, dass ihr im Rasenfunk mit dabei seid. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost und ich freue mich sehr, die gewohnte Runde hier zu haben und aber auch ein neues Mitglied. Chris McCaffey ist hier mit dabei. Er ist freier Journalist. Er war früher Gründer von 90 plus und er wird uns über die Premier League aufklären in der Zukunft. Chris, schön, dass du da bist. Sag doch mal ein paar Worte zu dir. Hi.
Ja, hi. Erst mal vielen Dank, dass du dabei sein darf. Freue mich dabei zu sein. Hallo in die Runde und ja, Premier League war schon immer so ein bisschen mein Steckenpferd. Schon die eine oder andere Sache darüber geschrieben. Früher freu ich mich ein bisschen und wie gesagt für 90 plus und ja, mit den Hebeln hab ich auch einen ganz guten Draht. Von daher bin ich der ideale Lückenfüller.
Ja, jetzt könnt ihr auch mal raten, wie Chris hier reingekommen ist. Ja, sehr, sehr schön, dass du mit dabei bist. Das bringt ein bisschen Abwechslung rein. Da freuen wir uns drüber. Davon lebt ja auch die Liga Tour ein bisschen und sie lebt ja auch davon, dass man nie weiß, was einen genau erwartet. Und ich sag mal so, Chris hat seine Themen geschickt, Nies hat seine Themen geschickt, Christian, über was möchtest du sprechen? Ja, schau, ich hab erstmal Hallo in die Runde logischerweise auch, Hallo Chris. Ja, ich hab mir gedacht, ich fang mit einem kleinen Quiz an. Ich hol euch erstmal mit rein, damit hier alle gleich mal wach werden.
Du, du, du, du.
Ich hab als Thema dabei die Mannschaft der Serie A, die in den letzten zehn Spieltagen die meisten Punkte geholt hat. Bin ich mal gespannt, was sie mir da jetzt so anbieten würde.
Florenz?
Hier haben wir schon mal einen Tipp.
Boehm.
Schau, schau da, Chris startet schon gleich mit einem Ding rein. Genau, ja, sehr stark. Ja, genau, ich hab euch die Roma mitgebracht, weil wir die Roma ja anfangen, das ist schon schon. Chris ist überqualifiziert, ich sag's ganz ehrlich. Du darfst dich nur bei der Premier League auskennen, Chris.
Ich hab nur schön auf die Tabelle geschaut.
Wir alle stehen sonst doof da. Ja, das stimmt, gleich schon mal, gleich schon mal, mit ganz hohem Niveau wird hier eingestiegen. Genau. Ja, ich hab die Roma mitgebracht, weil eben wie gesagt, wir hatten die Roma in der Saison ja schon zwei, dreimal, aber meistens eher wegen negativen Aspekten, weil es drunter und drüber ging. Und jetzt mittlerweile hat Claudia Ranieri eben die Roma soweit gebracht, dass die, und das finde ich schon beeindruckend, eben in den letzten zehn Spieltagen, wie gesagt, die meisten Punkte geholt haben. 24 ungeschlagen, 7 Siege, 3 Unentschieden, mehr Punkte als Napoli, mehr als Atalanta, mehr als Inter, mehr als alle anderen. Und das, finde ich, ist es schon wert, mal kurz zu beleuchten, weil wir ja schon über Ranieri auch vor ein paar Wochen mal gesprochen hatten, weil schon klar war, dass er das Ganze befriedet hat, sage ich mal, das ganze Umfeld. Er einfach mit seiner unfassbaren Erfahrung, mit seinem krassen Roma-Bezug eben auch es wirklich geschafft hat, dass da quasi wieder Ruhe in den Laden reinkommt. Und jetzt mittlerweile muss man aber halt auch sagen, er führt die halt so weiter, dass die halt echt ja auch einen sehr, sehr guten Fußball spielen und einen sehr erfolgreichen Fußball mittlerweile. Der schlägt sich jetzt tabellarisch noch nicht, weiß Gott, wie nieder. Sie sind immer noch neunte, weil sie halt einfach ein riesen Loch aufzuholen hatten. Aber allein, dass sie wieder an Milan dran sind, an Bologna, auch an der Fiorentina, zeigt, dass Claudia Ranieri da wirklich einen richtig guten Job macht. Und wie ihr es schon merkt, ich habe jetzt öfter über Ranieri gesprochen. Ich finde, es ist wirklich die Figur von Ranieri, die das transportiert, weil, wenn wir vielleicht noch mal kurz zurückgehen, die Anfänge von Ranieri in dieser Saison, also Ranieri war ja der dritte Roma-Trainer, das ging los mit der Rossi, der wurde nach dem vierten Spieltag geschmissen, dann kam Juric, absolute Katastrophe und dann kam eben Ranieri aus dem Ruhestand zurück. Und am Anfang hat er probiert, da einfach, sag ich mal, über eine ganz klare Elf über erfahrene Spieler einfach wieder Struktur reinzubekommen. Das ging los eben mit Mats Hummels, der davor kaum eine Rolle gespielt hat, Chef der Dreierkette, Paredes, Argentinier, Doppel-Sechs, da wieder Ordnung reingebracht hat, Angelino wieder linker Flügelspieler oder linker Schienenspieler. So, das war so am Anfang sein Credo und da hat er wirklich am Anfang mit 12, 13 Spielern gearbeitet. Also wirklich, um einfach wieder, ja, da das Ganze wieder ein bisschen strukturell zu bekommen. Und jetzt ist wirklich, würde ich sagen, die großartige Weiterentwicklung, dass mittlerweile in den vergangenen Wochen es funktionieren alle. Also es ist jetzt angefangen vielleicht das Gesicht momentan, dieses Roma-Aufschwungs des Mathias Soule, der junge Argentinier, der im Sommer für viel Geld von Juve geholt wurde, um die 30 Millionen. Ganz kreativer Mann, ja, technisch wahnsinnig stark. Der hat bis vor wenigen Wochen eigentlich kaum eine Rolle gespielt in dieser Saison, weil er eben von den ersten Trainer nicht wirklich gesehen wurde, war auch ein bisschen Druck logisch mit dabei, weil er viel Geld gekostet hat. Dann war er in dieser turbulenten Saison mit drin. Und auch Ranieri hat ihn am Anfang eben aus den Gründen, weil er so ein bisschen seine Stammelf hatte, da waren dann Pellegrini und Tiballa hinter Dovpik gesetzt, hat ihn kaum Minuten gegeben. Aber er hat immer wieder gesagt, schau, Soleil macht alles richtig, seine Zeit wird kommen und genau so ist es gekommen. Soleil hat jetzt wirklich am Montag, also die Roma hat 4-0 gegen Monza gewonnen, hat die wirklich hergespielt. Es ist klar, Monza ist mit Abstand die schlechteste Mannschaft im Moment in der Liga. Das ist jetzt nicht der Benchmark. Aber Soleil hat auch die Woche davor. Schaut euch das vielleicht nochmal an, wenn ihr so einen Oldschool-Freistoß mal sehen wollt. Ich sag nur 16er Linie, wo man das Gefühl hat, oh mein Gott, der ist eigentlich zu nah dran. Und dann streichelt er den drüber. Das war das Siegtreffer in Parma. Also wirklich, der Ball fliegt fast in Zeitlupe über die Mauer und geht dann ganz sachte oben ins Kreuz Eck rein. Jetzt am Wochenende hat er zwei Tore vorbereitet, war überhaupt nicht zu halten. Und das ist eben so ein bisschen das neue Gesicht, dass eben auch alle anderen funktionieren. Schumorodov vorne drin, Dovbek ist seit ein paar Spielen verletzt, kein Problem. Schumorodov trifft, Schumorodov bereitet vor. Cristante hat jetzt wieder getroffen, der eigentlich auch in der Saison kaum eine Rolle gespielt hat. Also ganz viele, er schafft jetzt sozusagen, alle mitzunehmen und deswegen ist die Roma wirklich eine sehr, sehr schöne Geschichte. Einziger Neomoment, sie sind vor kurzem in der Coppa Italie gegen Milan ausgeschieden. Das ist so wirklich das einzige der letzten Wochen, weil logisch wäre die Coppa Italie jetzt noch mit das Machbarste gewesen in der Saison. Aber in der Europa League sind sie auch noch im Rennen, haben auch da Porto, das war auch beeindruckend, wie sie Porto in Hin- und Rückspiel herausgenommen haben. Gerade im Rückspiel, da haben sie bis kurz vor Schluss 3-1 geführt, zwei sensationale Tore von Di Balla. Di Balla ist auch wieder einfach, ist in der Verfassung, wie man ihn vielleicht seit Jahren nicht hatte, dass er ist spritzig, er ist fit und wenn Di Balla spritzig und fit ist, der Rest ist ja eh sensationell. Also es ist wirklich an Harmonie kaum im Moment zu überbieten und da kann dann Nils vielleicht noch zwei Sätze dazu sagen, das wird jetzt echt ein Kracher gegen Athletic Bilbao im Achtelfinale, weil die sind auch in sehr, sehr guter Verfassung. Aber ich muss sagen, falls die Roma diese Hürde schafft, dann traue ich der Roma auch dieses Saison der Europa League alles zu, weil die eh die letzten Jahre bewiesen haben, dass sie diesen europäischen Weg sehr gut gehen können. Und deswegen echt nur Hut ab vor Claudia Ranieri, wie er das Roma-Schiff wieder mit seiner ruhigen Art und Weise auf Kurs gebracht hat. Das klingt wirklich sehr, sehr gut. Ich habe mir sofort das Bracket rausgelassen von der Europa League. Das könnte schon interessant werden. Also Bill Bauer, dann geht es gegen Fener oder die Rangers. Und danach kommt irgendjemand aus dem Zweig, Basel, Lyon, Real Sociedad und United. Also bis auf United nur Spitzenteams. Der lag zu nah, um ihn nicht zu machen. Aber dieses 1 zu 3 gegen Milan, das war nämlich das Spiel, das habe ich auch mitbekommen. Deswegen hatte ich dann erst im Nachhinein wieder auf dem Schirm, dass sie an der Liga tatsächlich nie verloren hatten. Was war da dann los in diesem einen Spiel? Ja, das ist relativ einfach zu erklären, weil da können wir jetzt stundenlang über Milan reden. Milan ist halt, ich weiß nicht, ob es im Moment eine launischere Diva in Europa gibt. Milan ist halt in einem Spiel zu allen fähig. Und da waren sie auch besser als die Romen, haben das sehr gut gemacht. Nils erinnert sich wahrscheinlich noch, vor ein paar Monaten hat Milan auch im Bernabéu gegen Real gewonnen und das auch alles andere als unverdient. Milan ist dann halt, aber das wäre ein eigenes Thema, scheidet dann halt gegen Ferdinand aus, weil sich, weil Theo Hernandez sich wegen der Schwalbe mit Gelb-Rot vom Platz stehen lässt und weil Mignan zweimal patzt und weil Pulisic jetzt zuletzt in der Liga einen Elfmeter verschießt. Also Milan war in dem Spiel besser, das war völlig okay. Und ja, deswegen wollte ich es auch anbringen. Das tut der Roma logischerweise weh, weil logisch wäre die Coppa Italia ist halt mit der Europa League halt noch die einzige Möglichkeit gewesen, um in der Saison Silberware zu holen. Aber wie gesagt, ich trau ihnen wirklich in der Europa League alles zu. Und es ist echt auch schön, auch Ranieri zu leben muss ich sagen, wenn er dann spricht vor den Spielen, nach den Spielen. Du merkst halt einfach, der Mann ruht in sich. Gut, wer sollte noch mehr in sich ruhen, also wahrscheinlich als Claudio Ranieri in dem Business. Aber er ist auch immer wieder punktuell. Er spricht dann auch Sachen klar an. Das war zum Beispiel sehr schön nach dem Porto-Spiel. Da hat eben die Roma, da waren sie dann über Zahl, die machen es 3-1, im Hinspiel war es 1-1, eigentlich war das Ding durch. Und kurz vor Schluss kassieren sie noch in Unterzahl das 3-2. Da war dann zwar nur noch eine Minute zu spielen und Porto hat auch nicht noch mal die große Chance gehabt. Aber Ranieri kommt halt in den Mikros und sagt, so als erstes sage ich euch ganz ehrlich, ich bin nicht in die Kabine rein, denn wenn ich in die Kabine reingegangen wäre, dann wäre es ungemütlich geworden, weil es kann nicht sein, dass so eine erfahrene, reife Mannschaft wie wir, wir sind in Überzahl 3-1 und dann fällt noch das 3-2. Also was ich damit sagen will, der ist jetzt nicht immer nur der liebe, nette Onkel, der hier nur alles streichelt, aber genau deshalb hat er halt einen wahnsinnig guten Zugang gefunden. Und wie gesagt, das für mich beeindruckend ist eben, dass halt alle mittlerweile funktionieren. Er zieht sie alle mit. Mats Hummels zum Beispiel hat jetzt vor dem Monsterspiel 3-mal nicht gespielt, aber auch nicht, weil irgendwas vorgefallen wäre, sondern einfach weil die anderen 3 hinten auch ohne ihn funktioniert haben. Also er hat wirklich sich ein ganz breites Spektrum erarbeitet und gerade zu Hummels vielleicht, das passt auch ganz gut. Da sieht man halt auch all die Erfahrungen von Ranieri. Das war glaube ich nach dem Milan-Spiel. Da hat er dann vor dem Ligaspiel hat er gemeint, so bevor ich sag's euch gleich, Hummels und Paredes, den habe ich beiden freigegeben. Die sollen mal ein paar Tage rauskommen. Die haben sehr viel gespielt die letzten Wochen. Sind logischerweise auch nicht mehr die Jüngsten, hat er gemeint. Deswegen ist mal gut, wenn die mal ein bisschen rauskommen, Kopf frei kriegen, auch nicht nur sich körperlicher holen können, sondern auch mental. Und auch daran merkt man halt einfach das Feingefühl. Er hat halt genau gemerkt, dass vielleicht gerade einer wie Hummels und Paredes so was brauchen kann. Und das passt halt. Also es ist wirklich ein sehr stimmiges Bild im Moment. Und deswegen, ja, in der Liga. Klar werden die jetzt, also Richtung Champions League ist es einfach zu weit weg. Ich glaube, selbst wenn die noch den Run fortführen, dafür ist der Rückstand zu groß. Aber sie haben, wie gesagt, sicherlich die große Hoffnung. Der Roma ist halt über der Europa League. Könntest du dich ja auch noch für die Champions League qualifizieren? Das ist sicherlich jetzt das große Ding. Und wie gesagt, es ist einfach eine schöne Geschichte zu sehen, dass der Mann, der dann ab dem Sommer ja eigentlich dann zum Berater werden soll, der jetzt ja auch schon im Prinzip im Hintergrund ein bisschen die Gespräche führt mit dem potenziellen nächsten Trainer, der dann im Sommer ja kommen soll, dass Ranieri halt wirklich nicht nur da wieder ein gutes Ambiente, eine gute Stimmung gesorgt hat, sondern wirklich da jetzt auch eine Mannschaft hingestellt hat, die einen guten Fußball spielt, die verlässlich punktet, die das Ambiente wieder mitgenommen hat und ja, deswegen finde ich absolut verdient, dass wir da Ranieri mal hervorheben. Aber wirklich. Also es geht gegen Athletic Bilbao, dann im Achtelfinale gegen die hat man schon in der Gruppenphase gespielt, ganz, ganz spät den 1 zu 1 Ausgleich noch gefangen, aber wenn sogar Ivan Juric es schafft gegen Athletic Bilbao einen Unentschieden zu holen, also dann kann man ja nur beten. Nein, ganz so ist es natürlich nicht. Wir schauen es uns an, aber sehr, sehr interessant das zu hören. Und ich würde sagen, ja, natürlich.
Ich habe nur noch einen kurzen Zusatz dazu. Ich fand es echt spannend, dass Christian gesagt hat, so die letzten zehn Spiele, Roma die beste, weil in der Liga ist es genau der Athletic Club, der in den letzten zehn Spieltagen die meisten Punkte geholt hat. Also echt gut ist, kommt gut was zusammen.
Europa liegt aktuell auf Champions-League-Niveau. Das ist Power-Ranking-Seat-Nummer-1. Nehmen sich Italien und Spanien schon mal schön gegenseitig raus. Das ist doch dann eine gute Nachricht. Vielleicht ja auch für Power-Ranking-Seat-Nummer-1 in England. Ist das dann Liverpool, Chris? Gibt es da eigentlich niemanden anderen, der sich so aufdrängt, oder?
Nee, ich habe wirklich gedacht, dass diese Sendung vielleicht könnte es darüber gehen, dass Liverpool in eine Schwächephase kommt, dass die anderen nachrücken. Aber ja, sie waren nicht in der besten Verfassung von einer Woche. Gegen Wolverhampton Grazow gewonnen, Bournemouth Grazow und dann stand ja noch Aston Villa, City und Newcastle an. Also das ist eigentlich so eine Phase, da kann man mal Punkte lassen, wenn man nicht in bester Form ist. Aber dann hat uns Liverpool ja wirklich gegen City vor allem dran erinnert, wie gut sie sind. Und vor allem haben uns Arsenal und City dran erinnert, was für große Probleme sie haben. Und dementsprechend seit gestern ist der Titel eigentlich gegessen, 13 Punkte. So ein großer Vorsprung wurde zu diesem Zeitpunkt der Saison seit in der Historie der ersten Liga, also seit 1888 nicht aufgeholt. Von daher denke ich, können wir Liverpool jetzt schon Glück wünschen.
Und das ist ja wirklich krass. Also wer hätte gedacht, dass Arne Slot so startet. Gleichzeitig kommt es aber nicht überraschend, weil wir haben es alle kommen sehen und irgendwann liefen dann so die Siege von Liverpool nebenher. Also man hat schon gar nicht mehr anders erwartet. Wo würdest du denn sagen, liegen denn die Schlüssel von Liverpool, weil das ist jetzt so früh passiert, das liegt da vor allem auch an den Gegnern, aber dass man so Konstantpunkte geholt hat, das liegt ja nur an Liverpool selbst.
Ja, absolut. Also gerade das City-Spiel war so ein kleiner Mikrokosmos der gesamten Saison irgendwie. Es war eine fantastische gesamtmannschaftliche Leistung. Man war hervorragend vom Trainer eingestellt und man hatte wie so oft in dieser Saison auch diese nötige Effizienz in den richtigen Momenten. Also es ist schon oft vorgekommen in dieser Saison, dass Liverpool vielleicht eine kurze Schwächephase hat im Spiel. Der Gegner hat irgendwie eine Top-Chance vermasselt im Gegenzug Konter-Salah 1-0. Also das gibt es oft bei Liverpool diese Saison. Und ja, also gegen City war es wie gesagt eine gute Zusammenfassung davon. Man war sehr gut auf City vorbereitet. Man hatte den geringsten Ballbesitz in dieser Saison, in diesem Spiel. Nicht weil man jetzt irgendwie mit großer Ehrfurcht ins Spiel gegangen ist, sondern weil man einfach wusste, dass City eine relativ statische Offensive momentan hat, dass sie sich schwer tun, Chancen zu kreieren. Haaland hat natürlich auch gefehlt. Das hat natürlich geholfen. Und dass City wirklich gerade im Umschaltspiel wirklich sehr gut zu knacken ist. Und genau darauf war dieser Matchplan ausgelegt. Man hat dann wie so oft über Salah zugeschlagen, nach dem Standard diesmal und ab da war es eigentlich gegessen. Also der erste Torschuss war dann drin. City hat sich abgerackert, aber Liverpool hat auch hervorragend verteidigt und hat dann später das 2-0 nachgelegt nach Vorarbeit von Salah. Also die Zahlen sind schon irre. Ich hab vor zwei Wochen schon über Salah gesprochen und er ist wirklich auch dieser große Schlüssel, muss man sagen. Gerade wenn man jetzt auf die Konkurrenz schaut, bei Arsenal fehlt der beste Spieler mit Zarca, bei City fehlt der beste Spieler mit Rodri, Liverpool hat seinen besten Spieler und er ist in der besten Form seines Lebens. Und das ist schon bezeichnend irgendwie. Er hat jetzt 25 Tore und 17 Vorlagen in 28 Spielen. Das sind 64% aller Liverpool-Tore und da kann man sich ja eigentlich ausrechnen, woran es da liegt. Also es ist eine hervorragende Saison. Wie du sagst, klar, die Konkurrenz schwächelt. Also alleine, wenn ich mir Arsenele gestern gegen Nottingham angucke, da bestand die Offensive beim Stand von 0 zu 0 in den letzten 10 Minuten aus Kieran Tierney, vierter Linksverteidiger, aus Mikkel Merino. Ja, der Mikkel Merino aus Dortmund, der ist nicht über Nachtstürmer geworden, sondern der ist die einzige Option, die man jetzt noch vorne hinstellen kann. Und rechts wurde ein 17-jähriger.
Hat doch gegen Kürschland geklappt.
Stimmt, stimmt, stimmt. Er hat auch schon zweimal getroffen, aber ich glaube, das wird keine Dauerlösung davon. Und auf der rechten Seite war ein 17-jähriger Ethan Baniere, der dann durch Raheem Sterling ersetzt wurde und Raheem Sterling 2025 ist leider nicht mehr Raheem Sterling 2021. Und von daher, da sieht man, wie groß die Verletzungsnot bei Arsenal ist und auch City über die Probleme dort wurde auch schon viel gesprochen, auch viele Verletzungsprobleme, Altern der Kader, Rodriweck. Also ja, das alles sind Riesenprobleme. Das sind Gründe, warum die beiden Teams nicht die Konkurrenten sind. Aber Liverpool ist nun mal auf 90-Punkte-Kurs und da hätten die anderen beiden so gut spielen können, wie sie wollten. Sie wären maximal Konkurrenten gewesen und nicht mit der Meisterschaft davon gelaufen.
Und was würdest du sagen, macht Arne Slot anders als Jürgen Klopp oder führt er das fort?
Ist ein bisschen von beiden. Auf Social Media wird gerade die Arsenal-Bubble so ein bisschen geneckt von den Liverpool-Fans, weil Mikkel Attetta immer von Phasen gesprochen hat, dass er jetzt in Phase 3 ist mit Arsenal und so weiter mit seinem Aufbau. Und aktuell ist es ziemlich beliebt bei den Liverpool-Fans von Phase 1 Slot zu sprechen, die direkten Titel herbringt. Ist natürlich nicht ganz so einfach, weil wenn man sich das mal anschaut bei Liverpool, es gab keinen signifikanten Sommertransfer dieses Jahr und Liverpool ist nicht in Phase 1. Es gab keinen Umbruch, es gab keinen Neuaufbau. Es ist eher Liverpool-Phase 4-5 und dazu gehört einfach wirklich auch viel Jürgen Klopp. Die Basis war da. Es ist ein Meisterschaftskader gewesen, als Slot übernahm und der hat ihn einfach noch weiterentwickelt. Es ist viel von den Kloppelementen noch da. Sie sind immer noch sehr pressingstark, sie sind unfassbar gut im Umschaltspiel, defensiv, offensiv. Und Slot hat das Ganze einfach noch ein bisschen weiterentwickelt und in vielen Situationen noch ein bisschen verstärkt. Es werden viele Dreiecke gebildet jetzt in der Offensive, also ein bisschen Pep Guardiola-Elemente. Und er tut sich auch sehr, er ist sehr gut darin, das Beste aus den Spielern zu holen. Also Trent Alexander-Arnold hat vielleicht als Rechtsverteidiger, Betonung auf Verteidiger, seine Schwächen. Aber was er für den Spielaufbau und die Chancenkreation von der Rechtsverteidigung in Position macht, das ist schon ein Cheatcode. Und das sind alles so Sachen, die Slott weiterentwickelt hat. Und dementsprechend, ja, es ist eine tolle Basis gewesen, die Slott aber wirklich sehr gut weiterentwickelt hat und auch ein bisschen neue Energie verpasst hat. Weil letzte Saison war Liverpool ja so ein bisschen, wie soll man sagen, es war ja dieses Last Dance, die Last Dance-Ambusphäre unter Jürgen Klopp. Aber man hat gemerkt, die Mannschaft war so ein bisschen auf dem Zahnfleisch. Es war vielleicht so ein bisschen eingefahren alles. Und Slott hat das Ganze wieder auf die richtige Bahn geführt.
Also aus Deutschland kenne ich es so, wenn die Meisterschaft früh entschieden ist, dann konzentriert sich alles logischerweise auf Pokalwettbewerbe. Da ist der interessante Fakt, also da treffen schon wieder Power-Ranking-Seeds No. 1 aufeinander, nämlich Liverpool gegen PSG. Also PSG, wir hatten die Ligue 1 jetzt schon länger nicht mehr mit dabei. Aber ihr werdet schnell Champions-League mitbekommen haben. Die sind gerade richtig gut unterwegs. Eines der besten Teams im Jahr 2025. Also darauf wird sich logischerweise konzentriert. Und das zweite große Thema ist dann aber ja immer, bei wem läuft der Vertrag aus und wie geht es weiter? Und wenn ich mir da angucke, Trent Alexander-Arnold läuft der Vertrag aus, Mo Salah wissen wir alle läuft der Vertrag aus, Virgil van Dijk läuft der Vertrag aus. Ist das auch wirklich ein großes Thema oder gibt es halt nichts anderes zu bereden?
Ich glaube schon, dass es ein großes Thema ist und da muss man auch Slot ein sehr großes Kompliment machen, weil solche Themen können schon eine Mannschaft aus dem Ruder bringen und das hat er sehr gut anscheinend intern bewältigt bekommen. Und ja, also man merkt schon, dass das Thema ist. Man muss auch sagen, man ist in der relativ komfortablen Position, dass man im Titelkampf jetzt nie unter den ganz großen Druck geraten ist. Also das hilft natürlich auch, das macht das Ganze ein bisschen bequemer und leichter damit umzugehen. Nichtsdestotrotz hat man das natürlich toll bewältigt. Aber ich sag mal, für die Saison ist es jetzt kein Thema mehr. Jeder weiß, um was es geht. Wobei ich es ein bisschen enttäuschen fand, dass Trent Alexander-Arnold so öffentlich, ja nicht öffentlich, aber so konkret mit Real geflirtet hat im Winter, wenn er mit seinem Jugendclub hier die Meisterschaft gewinnen kann, hätte man vielleicht ein bisschen anders lösen können. Aber nichtsdestotrotz, wenn ich gerade von dieser Phase 4, 5 und Liverpool gesprochen hab, wie du sagst, die Verträge laufen aus, alles von wird auch nicht jünger. Man könnte da ganz schnell wieder auf Phase 3, wenn ich jetzt bei diesem Narrativ bleib, abstürzen im Sommer. Und dann ist es lott natürlich wirklich gefragt, hier die richtigen Transfers zu tätigen, die idealen Nachfolger zu finden und das Ganze wirklich auf diesem Level auch zu halten. Weil die drei Spieler, insbesondere die drei, sind wirklich der Hauptgrund, warum Liverpool so gut ist dieses Jahr.
Und kannst du das von außen betrachtet dann aber nachvollziehen, dass man da nicht das Geld in die Hand nimmt, um mit ihnen zu verlängern? Also klar, es ist sehr, sehr viel Geld, aber Liverpool wird auch einen richtigen Haufen Kohle jetzt verdienen. Durch alle Wettbewerbe, die kommen, Club WM und so weiter ist ja auch noch mit dabei. Also wir müssen uns generell erstmal keine Sorgen um die Finanzen von Liverpool machen. Also warum ist man da nicht aggressiver oder macht es zumindest früher klar? Also es ist ja bei Mo Salah ist es ja relativ wild. Du hörst irgendwann Ende Dezember, ja gut, also er ist weg. Anfang Januar kommt, achso, nee, er verlängert wahrscheinlich. Und ich mein klar, das sind jetzt die Medien und da wird dann jedes Wort von ihm überinterpretiert und die Berater mischen mit und so weiter. Aber du hast es ja schon gesagt, das ist ja eigentlich bemerkenswert, dass man es eigentlich nicht in der sportlichen Leistung irgendwie wiederfindet, dieses Hin und Her.
Ja und umso beachtlicher ist auch, man hat in den ein oder anderen Interviews von ihm auch gemerkt, wie unzufriedener er ist über die gesamte Thematik. Und dass man dann trotzdem so performt, ist natürlich auch beachtlich. Ja, es ist schwer zu sagen. Wir wissen natürlich nicht, ob die Angebote von Liverpool zu niedrig waren. Wir wissen nicht, ob die Spieler vielleicht in Anführungszeichen zu viel wollen und man sich deswegen nicht findet. Man sollte aber betonen, dass man sich beim FC Liverpool wirklich, dass man da bemüht ist, auch ein sehr nachhaltiges Projekt zu fahren. Dass man sich hier nicht irgendwie groß verschuldet, sondern dass man nachhaltig wirtschaftet. Und ja, man müsste sich mal die Gehaltsliste genau anschauen. Man ist da definitiv sehr weit oben dabei. Man ist auch höher als Arsenal mit den Gehältern. Aber ich denke schon, dass man zumindest mit Salah und Van Dijk insbesondere durchaus verlängern möchte. Jetzt bleibt natürlich abzuwarten, was die Spieler wollen. Weil Van Dijk, glaube ich, dass die Tendenz eher Richtung Verbleib geht. Salah finde ich wirklich schwer vorherzusagen. Gerade weil er sich auch schlecht behandelt fühlte. Aber anstelle von Liverpool würde ich wirklich alles daran setzen, Salah nochmal zu verlängern, weil ich denke mit diesem Kern dieser Mannschaft kann man jetzt hier vielleicht noch ein, zwei Jahre Vollgas geben, solange Salah eben noch in dem Alter ist, dass er das kann. Er ist jetzt, glaube ich, 32. Scheint auch gut zu altern von seiner Spielweise, wie man das jetzt aktuell so sieht. Von daher wäre schon der Schlüssel, glaube ich, dass man jetzt hier die nächsten ein, zwei Jahre wirklich um alle Titel spielen kann.
Es ist eine interessante Situation, weil man ja auch ins Stadion investiert. Deshalb sind die Schulden, also musste man Kredite aufnehmen. Da muss man dann natürlich auch achten unter den Financial Fair Play Regeln. Also jetzt nicht der UEFA, die sind ja relativ zahnlos, was die großen Teams angeht, aber die der Premier League, da dann quasi auch drunter zu bleiben und endlos wachsen kann es dem Merchandising nicht. Das ist also ganz so einfach, wie ich es gesagt habe, ist es nicht. Aber interessant ist es schon, wie es Liverpool aktuell angeht, indem man es voll außen betrachtet nicht angeht. Intern werden sie natürlich reden, aber nicht so, dass es geklappt hätte. Aber Christian, du wolltest glaube ich noch was sagen. Ja, ganz kurz, weil ich fand den Punkt, den du da reingepackt hast, macht es wirklich sehr spannend. Ich würde nur zwei, drei Zahlen dazu nennen, weil ich ein paar Zahlen aus Italien kenne. Allein Inter hat in der Gruppenphase der Champions League 86 Millionen Euro eingenommen. Also können wir davon ausgehen, dass es bei Liverpool nochmal mehr war, weil die ja nochmal souveräner durch sind. Dazu kommen eben, in Italien heißt das allein für die Teilnahme im Sommer an der Club WM 50, 60 Millionen einfach. Die landen bei dir schon direkt auf dem Konto, ohne dass du da eine Sekunde gespielt hast. Also was ich sagen will, den Batzen Geld, den sich Liverpool jetzt auch nochmal zusätzlich in der Saison durch diese großartige Saison erspielt, ist schon nicht auch für den Premier League Club nicht unerheblich. Und deswegen finde ich es spannend, wie es Chris sagt, weil ja Liverpool anscheinend da wirklich auch ein bisschen einen nachhaltigen Ansatz hat. Ich glaube jetzt auch nicht, dass sie das Geld eben einfach rausballern, aber ich würde mal schon vermuten, dass dir all diese krassen Plus, die da wirklich, und wie gesagt da sind wir halt im dreistelligen Millionenbereich, dass dir das dann vielleicht halt auch bei der einen oder anderen Vertragsverhandlung, wenn es dann jetzt in die heiße Phase geht, du logischerweise du willst nicht dein Gehaltsgefüge sprengen, das ist mir schon völlig klar und das machen die sicherlich auch nicht, aber du hast halt vielleicht doch den kleinen, einen oder anderen kleinen finanziellen Handlungsspielraum mehr, den du dir wirklich im wahrsten Sinn das Wortes erspielt hast in dieser Saison, durch diese bislang so grandiose Saison.
Ja, das ist definitiv der einzige Punkt ist halt wirklich, dass die Fenway Sports Group natürlich auch da eine gewisse Strategie fährt. Und wie gesagt, die wollen nachhaltig funktionieren. Und wenn man jetzt mal ganz nüchtern, gefühlslos auf die Zahlen guckt, man redet hier davon einen 32-Jährigen und einen 33-Jährigen mit einem sehr saftigen Vertrag auszustatten. Bei Verteidigern kann das ganz gut ausgehen, bei Salah. Wie gesagt, er macht keine Anzeichen, dass er jetzt irgendwann jetzt aufwärts zu performen, aber ein 32-jähriger Offensivspieler, der auch viel über die Schnelligkeit macht, das kann, wenn du ihm jetzt irgendwie einen Vierjahresvertrag gibst, das kann übel ausgehen und man hat natürlich auch keinen Weiterverkaufswert.
Und dann ist der Klassiker ja in dieser Phase der Karriere, dass es dann oft eben an den Vertragslaufzeiten hängt. Der Spieler hätte gerne quasi seinen Rentenvertrag in Anführungszeichen, drei Jahre, vier Jahre und der Verein sagt, also ein Jahr geben wir dir auf jeden Fall, aber dann wollen wir neu gucken. Beide Seiten sind zu verstehen. Mal gucken, wie es da weitergeht. Auf jeden Fall total interessant, wie Liverpool die Premier League in einer Art und Weise weg dominiert. Und man sich aber so schnell daran gewöhnt hat, dass es dann auch hier gar nicht so oft thematisiert wurde, weil eben die ganzen brennenden Reifenstapel links und rechts dann doch irgendwie wichtiger waren, doch mal drauf zu gucken. Aber Liverpool, bin sehr gespannt, wie es da auch gegen PSG weitergeht. Also die nächste Runde in den Europapokalen. Jetzt geht es echt los, Leute. Aber ist ja auch, das ist ja quasi March Madness, gibt es ja nicht nur im US-Sport, sondern so ein bisschen ist es ja auch im Fußball ab März. Dann zählt es. Und ein bisschen haben wir das ja auch schon gemerkt in der Copa del Rey, würde ich sagen. Denn da hat also mindestens ein Spiel stattgefunden, von dem haben ganz, ganz viele Hörerinnen und Hörer mitbekommen, was sich da Barca und Atletico geliefert haben. Irre einfach nur. Führ uns durch. Was war da los in dem beiden Halbfinale Hinspielen?
Ja, konnte man sich auch als Real Madrid Fan gut anschauen, wie sich die beiden da gegenseitig die Tore hin und her werfen. Also war schon ein lustiges Hinspiel.
Mit wem hält man es da als Real Madrid Fan?
Nein, du kennst das schon. I hope both teams lose. Das ist natürlich das erste Mal. Und am besten auch die Schiedsräder verlieren. Aber nee, war aus neutraler Sicht ging das gut hin und her. Man hat gemerkt, wie Barca's Pressing immer noch gut funktioniert, was die an Tiefe im Spiel reinkriegen, wie schnell es da geht. Und da fliegt da, wo auch wirklich Atletico mit einer auch guten Defensive in dieser Saison auch ordentlich gewackelt hat. Auch wenn man jetzt mal die Anfangsphase ausklammert, da hat der Atletico 2-0 geführt nach sechs Minuten. Danach die vier Tore gingen auf Barsas Konto. Das ging dann auch ziemlich schnell, ehe da, wer war es, Pedri und Pauko Basi mit seinem ersten Barca-Treffer geantwortet hatten, auch nach Ecken. Also wo man denkt, das ist doch jetzt Atletico-Stärke, wenn da ein langer Ball kommt, da denken sich doch Riemindes und Kujakul entspannt weiter. Aber nee, selbst da hat Flick Standardvarianten einstudiert lassen und dann hat es ein bisschen vielleicht dran gescheitert, dass du nicht gleich noch mehr Tore gemacht hast, dass da zum Beispiel Lewandowski geschont wurde. Ferran Torres hatte so ein, zwei Chancen noch vergeben. So stand es dann irgendwann nur 4 zu 2. Lewandowski kam ja noch, hat natürlich noch gestochen und dann dachte man, das war es jetzt. Jolenta hat noch ein bisschen Ergebniskosmetik in der 84. betrieben, aber wieder Atletico, super Klatsch, die sind in Europa, das hat Transfermarkt rausgefunden, in Europas Top-Ligen. Die Mannschaft mit den meisten Toren nach der 80. Minute, 28 Stück sind das. Danach kommen so Eindhoven, PSG, Real Madrid, die Bayern mit 21 Treffern. Also die hatten schon das Liga hinspielt bei Barcelona in der 94. oder so gewonnen. Jetzt dann auch eben Stirlot wieder in der 94. getroffen. Da dann eben noch das 4-4 erzielt. Also das war irre mit, wie gesagt, noch mehr Chancen für theoretisch noch mehr Tore. Und wo man auch gemerkt hat, dass da auch Atletico defensiv wackeln kann, wenn Barca wirklich sein Pressing so hoch fährt. Aber dieses hohe Verteidigen führt dann auch hier und da zu zu Kontern, hat dann auch eben Atletico natürlich ausgenutzt, wobei auch da sehr zu erwähnt sind Grießmann und Julian Alvarez, absolute Unterschiedspieler, die da diese Weltklasse regelmäßig aufs Feld bringen, auch in der Liga. Von dem her war das ein lustiges, abwechslungsreiches erstes Hinspiel im Kovalerei-Halbfinal. Das dauert jetzt über einen Monat bis zu den Rückspielen, aber das war schon mal wild und lustig.
Ich habe auch jetzt ein Quiz für euch. Heute ist es offenbar die Quiz-Ausgabe der Ligatur. 28 Tore nach der 80. Minute plus Nachspielzeit. Schätzfrage, wie viele Bundesligisten haben in der Bundesliga in der gesamten Saison weniger als 28 Tore erzielt? Es sind fünf. Ich nehme es euch ab. Ich meine klar, es sind natürlich mehr Spiele bei Atletico wegen Europapokal usw. Aber das möchte ich nur eben einmal vorheben, also es sind mehr Tore als Augsburg, Heidenheim, Bochum, Union und natürlich St. Pauli in der gesamten Bundesligasaison bisher erzielt haben, die Atletico allein ab der 80. Minute gemacht hat. Nicht so schlecht.
Und 16 davon sogar nach der 90. Minute, das ist ja auch Leverkusen von dieser Qualität, hat davon gekostet, Real Madrid hat da den Ausgleich erzielt. Also die sind schon auch klatsch, wie man immer sagt, klatsch lädt Atletico, weil sie auch einen super breiten Kader haben, weil dann immer mal noch ein Sirloot in Korea eingewechselt wird, Simeone's Sohn funktioniert. Also da hat einfach Tigo Simeone seinen Kader auch ziemlich gut im Griff, mit einer breiten Bank, wo immer noch was kommen kann. Das war jetzt wie gesagt zum zweiten Mal Sirloot gegen Barca mit einem späten Treffer. Das ist schon bemerkenswert.
Gibt's in der Kuppa der Rallye die Auswärtstor-Regel?
Nee, wurde auch abgeschafft. Also wenn es da jetzt dann nur eins-eins das Rückspiel ausgehen sollte im Metropolitano, dann geht's Verlängerung.
Die gibt's noch.
Die wurde in der Superkuppa gestrichen, da würde es direkt ins Elfmeterschießen gehen. Aber die Regel gibt's noch.
Okay, also 98. Minute, dann 1-1 Atletico und dann Verlängerung. Wir wissen doch genau schon, was passiert. Das war das eine Halbfinale-Hinspiel mit eben diesem wilden Verlauf und dem 4 zu 4. Und dann gab's noch ein zweites Halbfinale-Hinspiel. Und warum wirst du mir jetzt verkaufen, dass das auch besprechenswert ist, Nies? Es war ein 1 zu 0 von Real. Das klingt, da schlaf ich ja schon beim Lesen des Ergebnisses ein.
Ja, ich war auch Thema Arbeitssieg, aber es ist halt noch so frisch, dass sich manche Rasenpunkte zuhören. Was ist eigentlich in Spanien los, dass jetzt einfach diese Kuppa-Halbfinale-Hinspiele waren? Deswegen wollte ich das so kurz reinnehmen. Und da hat Real Madrid eben einen Arbeitszug bei Real Sociedad eingefahren, wenigstens als Kapitän. Sehr entspannt gewesen, sehr positive Körpersprache, also mit der Binde ist er auch ein ganz anderer Typ gewesen, der nicht regelmäßig meckert oder so. Das war positiv. Hendrik hat das entscheidende Tor gemacht nach Bellingham Vorlage. Real Sociedad hat auch seine Chancen. Lounien seine Paraden, aber auch auf der anderen Seite. Remiro, auch Top-Torhüter, hat auch seine Paraden. Also es hätte auch gut 13-2 für Real Madrid ausgehen können. Geht in Ordnung der Sieg, ist jetzt aber nicht die ganz große Geschichte. Außer dass Real da so ein bisschen mit einer B-11 angetreten ist, wie der Güle, Endrick, Lounien im Tor gewesen. Von dem her, da traut sich Ancelotti ein bisschen Rotationen zu. Christian hatte vorhin auch gesagt, so italienische Trainer und erst mal so diese 12, 13 Spieler. Ja, das habe ich auch bei Ancelotti so erfahren oder kennt man so auch von Ancelotti, nur halt in der Coppa del Rey. Rotiert ein bisschen durch und ja, ist da eben auch schon mal mit einem halben Bein oder lass es ein Bein sein im Finale am 26. April in Sevilla. Mal gucken, ob Klassik oder Derby, aber Rückspiel ist ja noch.
Wir haben ja erst in der letzten Ligatur über die oberen drei gesprochen. Es hat sich aber wieder schon ein bisschen was getan. Also Barca und Real sind jetzt punktgleich, dahinter Atletico ein Punkt weniger. Und gerade bei Real spürt man ja so ein bisschen den Unmut. Also man ja, man hat Manchester City weggemacht in den Playoffs, aber das war ja irgendwie klar, wenn Real da hinfällt, auch wenn man dort noch nicht gewonnen hat. Aber das war jetzt eben auch mal drin. Hat sich das denn alles wieder so ein bisschen beruhigt? Ich lese bei Blue Sky und so weiter schon noch relativ viele Kommentare zu Schiedsrichterleistungen und so weiter und so fort. Scheint mir alles gerade sehr aufgeregt zu sein bei Madrid.
Es ist nach wie vor aufgeregt im Sinne von, dass es da jetzt einfach so zwei, drei Spiele in der Liga gab, wo es gewisse Fehlentscheidungen gab, die dann gegen Real Madrid liefen, wo natürlich jetzt auch viel zusammen kam. Real Madrid TV macht natürlich trotzdem vor und nach den Spielen seine Schiedsrichter-Zusammenfassung, wann der Schiedsrichter mal so und so gemacht hat. Gestern zum Beispiel Sanchez Martinez hat sehr souverän gespielt. Es gab auch zwischendurch eine Unterbrechung wegen Todeswünschen für einen Real Madrid Spieler, aber da hat er das Protokoll erfüllt. Das lief so weit eigentlich dann von der Schiedsrichterleistung her in einer soliden Bahn.
Aber wie du das wegmoderierst, Nils, kommt das so oft vor?
Man hat schon öfter mal Moerete, Vini Moerete, stirb gerufen oder in dem Fall jetzt Asensio, Stirrprufe, das gibt es schon öfter mal. Also neben xenophoben rassistischen Äußerungen auch mal sowas. Aber in Spanien merkt man halt weiter, dass Real Madrid da auf Kriegsfuß ist mit den Verbänden, also Liga-Verbanden, also dem Nationalen Verband und eben da Veränderung anstrebt und dann auch da sich eine Schlammschlacht natürlich entwickelt, wenn dann ein Tebas-Liga-Präsident darauf angesprochen wird und der wieder sagt, ja wir hatten mal das versucht, da war Real Madrid dagegen und dann wir machen das alles so und das müssen die entscheiden. Also es wird sich die Verantwortung so ein bisschen hin und her geschoben und trotzdem ist so ein bisschen, es bahnt sich so ein bisschen Veränderung an, da jetzt auch ein Gremium gegründet wurde, wo auch unter anderem vier Klubs rein gewählt wurden, um damit zu Ideen zu besprechen, der FC Sevilla unter anderem. Also es könnte sich was tun, damit da ein bisschen mehr Transparenz in den Schiedsrichterprozess reinkommt. Tebas sagt auch immer so ein bisschen das deutsche Modell vom Aufbau her, aber da jetzt die genauen Unterschiede kenn ich da unten.
Wollen wir kurz die anderen drei Klubs raten, die in dem Gremium sind? Ich hab noch nie von dem Gremium gehört, aber du hast gesagt, Sevilla ist schon mit dabei, also ist der Rest Barca, Reale und Atletico?
Nee, es sind zwei Zweitligisten, zwei Erstligisten, aber ich kenn tatsächlich nur den Namen vom FC Sevilla, die waren die Einzigen, glaube ich, die da eine Pressemitteilung hatten.
Das ist ja interessant. Wahrscheinlich haben sie irgendein Farmteam noch mit reingesteckt. Na gut, da können wir natürlich gespannt sein, was dann diese Kommission ausarbeitet, ob man damit dann zufrieden ist. Aber ja, ich meine, bei Real wissen wir ja auch, auch da wird sich das Wohl und Weh der Saison sowieso erst jetzt dann, jetzt in diesen März, April und wer weiß, wie weit es noch in den Mai reingeht, Wochen entscheiden. Ich meine, man hat Anfang März das Heimspiel gegen Atletico in der Champions League, dann das Rückspiel. Das ist natürlich auch eine ganz fantastische Auslosung. Also wie gesagt, man kann ganz, ganz viel doof finden an der Europapokalreform, aber die nächste Runde, die knallt einem so dermaßen die Spiele um die Fresse. Und wenn man so will, könnte man ja auch sagen, dass auch in der Bundesliga die Number-One-Seat und Number-Two-Seat gegeneinander in der Champions League spielen. Also eigentlich müsste man jedes dieser Spiele sehen. Du, ich kenne Verantwortliche bei Sendern, die gucken da mit ganz, ganz bangem Blick hin, wie sich die nächste Runde aus deutscher Sicht entwickelt, weil das könnte sehr, sehr schmerzhaft werden. Aber es ist schon, also Europapokal, eigentlich müssten wir die Europapokal-Wochen hier im Rasenfunk machen und da jedes Spiel durch extrazieren. Ich fürchte, das werde ich leider nicht hinkriegen. Nein, ich weiß sogar, ich werde es nicht hinkriegen. Das ist ja schon nächste Woche. Naja, also das ist das Copa de Rey Halbfinale gewesen. Ich bin sehr, sehr, sehr gespannt, wie es in der Liga weitergeht. Wirklich sehr spannend, was da gerade in den Ligen passiert. Christian, wir wollen jetzt noch mal so ein bisschen schneller durch die Ligen durchgehen. Was hast du denn noch aus Italien mitgebracht? Ja, da müssen wir auch ganz frisch, da hat auch uns die Copa Italia was geliefert am gestrigen Abend. Juve ist ausgeschieden im Viertelfinale, und zwar gegen Empoli zu Hause, gegen den drittletzten der Tabelle, der letzten elf Spiele neun verloren hat. Auch noch ein bisschen ein paar junge Spiele hat lassen, weil für die geht es halt in erster Linie darum, drin zu bleiben in der Liga. Und das war jetzt wirklich ein Tiefpunkt. Also Juve ist im Elfmeterschießen ausgeschieden, aber es war halt 60 Minuten lang wirklich unterirdisch. Und das hat dann Thiago Motta auch zum allerersten Mal öffentlich gemacht. Also er ist vor die Mikros getreten, hat gesagt, ich habe mich heute geschämt für meine Mannschaft, für meine Spieler. Gemeint, wir haben den Boden erreicht. Er hat sowas noch nie erlebt, hat er gesagt. Man kann im Fußball halt, er hat wirklich sehr, sehr explizite Lyrik verwendet. Er hat gemeint, das hat er auch noch nie gemacht, noch bei keiner seiner Stationen, auch nicht bei Bologna oder Spezia, dass er seine Spieler so öffentlich angeht, weil er normalerweise eigentlich einer immer ist, der sich immer vor die Mannschaft gestellt hat. Er hat gesagt, diesmal kann ich es einfach nicht, weil wir von Anfang an hat er gemeint, Einsatz und Wille vermissen haben lassen. Also einfach die Basis. Ist er wirklich fast schon ein bisschen philosophisch geworden. Er hat auch gemeint, das ist nicht nur die Basis im Fußball, sondern auch im Leben. Und deswegen hat er gesagt, wenn das nicht da ist, dann erschämt sich und hat sich logischerweise auch als Hauptschuldigen da austituliert, weil er gemeint hat, ich hab's anscheinend nicht geschafft, quasi das in die Köpfe die Wichtigkeit des Spiels zu bringen. Und das Problem aus Jubelsicht ist halt jetzt, das ist halt am Ende einer Woche, wo es in der Vorwoche eben auch in der Champions League ausgeschieden sind, in den Playoffs gegen PSV. Was jetzt halt auch nicht einer, also wenn City, sicherlich ist City sehr enttäuscht, in den Playoffs auszuscheiden. Aber ich würde mal sagen, es ist halt ein Unterschied, ob ich gegen Real rausgehe oder ob ich gegen PSV rausgehe. Und das ist jetzt halt das große Problem bei Juve, dass jetzt innerhalb einer Woche im Prinzip du dich aus, viel zu früh aus der Champions League dich verabschiedet hast, jetzt indiskutabel aus der Koppa raus bist. Und es ist im Prinzip eigentlich nur noch darum geht, in der Liga diesen Platz 4 zu holen, also das absolute Minimalziel, um nächstes Jahr halt eben auch Champions League zu spielen. Und deswegen hat der Winter jetzt halt einfach in dieser Woche wieder massiv gedreht Richtung Juve oder auch Richtung Thiago Mota. Denn muss man ihn fairerweise zugute halten. In der Liga haben sie jetzt so eine Konstanz zuletzt erreicht, die sie eigentlich das ganze Jahr noch nicht hatten. Sie haben jetzt viermal in Folge gewonnen, da waren sie ewig weit weg. Darunter war auch der Derby d'Italia-Sieg gegen Inter erst vor kurzem. Also in der Liga haben sie echt jetzt erstmal ein bisschen die Kurve bekommen, aber das Spacefay aus und jetzt eben dieses Empoli aus, hat jetzt halt echt da komplett den Wind drehen lassen. Und Thiago Motta steht halt echt jetzt voll im Wind. Und das Schlimme daran, würde ich sagen, ist, vielleicht erinnern wir uns noch an den Sommer. Da war halt einfach diese Hoffnung da und auch das Gefühl am Anfang, jetzt kommt endlich etwas Neues bei Juwe. Nach den drei allegrieren Jahren, die halt so im Prinzip wie so ein eingemottetes altes Haus, wo jeder wusste, da müssen die Fenster aufgerissen werden, da muss jetzt einfach frischer Wind rein. Dann kam dieser frische Wind mit Yago Motta, eben mit einem Trainer, der einfach für was Neues steht, für eine gewisse Jugendlichkeit, ein sehr talentierter Trainer, viele neue Spieler, eine sehr junge Mannschaft. Also all das war ja am Anfang da, das hat sich auch die ersten Wochen ein bisschen transportiert. Aber dann muss man sagen, ist auch in der Liga relativ schnell die Realität eingekehrt. Juwe hat, erinnert sich wahrscheinlich auch die meisten, diese ewige Unentschiedensserie. Also im Prinzip hat sich Juwe auch relativ schnell, sag ich mal aus dem Titelrennen rausgenommen, nicht falsch verstehen. Niemand hat von Thiago Motta auch nicht bei Juwe am Anfang der Saison den Meistertitel erwartet. Das war allen klar, dass das jetzt logisch erstmal ein Jahr eins ist. Aber dass du so früh halt einfach auch überhaupt nicht mehr mitspielst, das ist logischerweise auch nicht jubelike. Und jetzt stehen wir halt da Ende Februar, Anfang März. Juwe hat die Supercoppa im Halbfinale gegen Milan verloren, ist aus der Champions League in den Playoffs raus, ist aus der Coppa raus und ist halt seit Monaten im Prinzip auch nicht im Titelrennen präsent. Und das ist jetzt schon eine sehr heftige Phase. Also muss man auch sagen, merkt man auch medial, dass Thiago Motta wirklich massiv wieder unter Druck ist. Und ich bin echt gespannt, wie sie sich da jetzt rauskriegen. Also wie gesagt, der Druck ist groß, sie sind in einer guten Position. Sie sind jetzt erstmal alleinig erfiert, haben zwei Punkte Vorsprung auf Lazio. Milan, Bologna liegen doch ein paar Punkte zurück. Heute Abend ist Milan Bologna noch das Nachrufspiel, das ist wichtig. Wenn da einer gewinnt, dann rückt der nochmal ein bisschen näher. Also Juve ist so in Sachen Platz 4 schon in einer guten Position. Aber das ist wirklich das absolute Minimalziel. Und deswegen der letzte Satz für mir dazu. Das ist halt auch so ein bisschen das Tragische aus Juves Sicht, dass diese Leichtigkeit, so ein bisschen dieses Frische, was am Anfang da war, jetzt halt wieder da ein massiver Schleier wieder drauf legt. Also ich will jetzt logisch, ich will in keiner Weise Thiago Motta jetzt mit Allegri vergleichen, aber Fakt ist halt all dieses bisschen Positive, das da war, das ist jetzt spätestens nach dieser Woche, nach den PSV-Haus und den Empolier-Haus komplett weggewischt. Da wickt jetzt echt wieder ein schwerer Schleier drauf und der schwere Schleier liegt auf einer sehr jungen Mannschaft, die im Alter im Durchschnitt 25 Jahre ist, die dementsprechend relativ unerfahren ist. Auf einem Trainer, der noch nie bei einem großen Club war, der merkt, dass bei Juve halt auch ein anderer Wind weht, der noch nie die Doppelbelastung hatte quasi. Und ja, das ist jetzt echt eine heftige Gemengelage, würde ich sagen. Aber absolut. Und ich hatte jetzt das Empoli-Spiel, das hatte ich noch gar nicht mitbekommen. Aber wirklich eine Katastrophe. Also muss man echt sagen. Also ich habe auch, also ich meine, wissen wir, Trainer sind manchmal in der Emotion, aber das war wirklich, Juve hat in der ersten Hälfte keinen Fuß aufs Feld bekommen. Und Juve hat mit der nominalen Startelf gespielt. Also er hat auch zum ersten Mal Vladović plus Kolomija nie spielen lassen. Das war so ein bisschen die Hoffnung, die beide mal. Es hat Coop Miners gespielt. Coop Miners ist auch so ein bisschen das Bild, der teuerste Mann des Sommers, der immer noch nicht in den Flow reingekommen ist. Also man muss da nicht nur über Thiago Mota reden, auch ein bisschen das viele Geld zur Erinnerung. Nur Juve hat im Sommer 180 Millionen ausgegeben. Also Thiago Mota hat schon einiges an Material bekommen. Jetzt ist klar, dass du das nicht von Anfang an zu einem perfekten Puzzle zusammenfügen kannst. Aber da ist schon viel Potenzial geholt worden und gerade Coop Meiners und Douglas Lewis, die haben zusammen um die 110, 120 gekostet. Die sind halt so ein bisschen das Gesicht dieses Weges, der halt noch nicht funktioniert und dementsprechend. Also das war wirklich gestern, das war unterirdisch und deswegen gut von Thiago Mota das auch so klar anzusprechen, aber halt logischerweise er hat dadurch den Druck auch nochmal auf sich massiv erhöht und nochmal Juve ist halt einfach, Juve ist in Italien, auch wenn es die letzten Jahre nicht mehr sportlich erfolgreich war, aber die absolute Nummer eins, was Aufmerksamkeit, was Druck betrifft, das ist eine andere Nummer. Ich bin weiterhin davon überzeugt, dass Thiago Mota ein sehr talentierter Trainer ist, aber er kriegt jetzt halt zum ersten Mal mit, das Juve-Ambiente ist halt ein anderes als Bologna, das Betsy hat bei allem Respekt. Und deswegen bin ich jetzt echt sehr gespannt, wie sie das den nächsten Wochen hinkriegen. Letzter Punkt dazu, einzig positive vielleicht, oder was man Juve-Fans vielleicht positiv mitgeben kann, dadurch, dass sie jetzt überall raus sind, hat sich Thiago Mota jetzt halt auch in die Lage gebracht, dass er zumindest die letzten drei Monate wieder Woche für Woche arbeiten kann. Also Sonntag bis Sonntag oder Samstag bis Samstag. Denn ich glaube schon, dass das auch ein großer Punkt in der Saison war. Nochmal auch für ihn war es zum ersten Mal diese Doppelbelastung, dass du halt auch, dass du immer Samstag, Mittwoch, Sonntag, Dienstag spielst. Das hat der so im Training halt auch noch nie. Und jetzt kann er zumindest seine Einhalte bis zum Saisonlande Woche für Woche vermitteln. Vielleicht kommt dadurch ein bisschen mehr Stabilität rein, aber es ist eine kritische Situation. Seit gestern Abend definitiv. Absolut. Aber immerhin auch Juve wird Club WM spielen. Also Kohle wird auch nicht das Thema sein. Aber das ist der nächste Punkt. Mal schauen, wie die dann rauskommen Richtung nächste Saison, wenn die keine richtige Vorbereitung haben. Also ja, aber kein Mitleid mit Teams, die sich die Etage vormachen. Also da hau ich jetzt schon in die Riegel rein. Ich weiß, dass die Spiele sich auch nicht ausgesucht haben, aber also. Ich wollte es nicht als Mitleid verstanden wissen, Max. Ich sage nur, ich weiß nicht, wie sehr das zuträglich ist für die kommende Saison, aber Mitleid muss man definitiv nicht haben. Das stimmt. Jetzt sind wir schon so richtig in der schlechten Laune gelandet mit Juve. Da können wir auch direkt mit Leicester weiter machen, Chris. Da ist auch so einiges im Argen.
Ja, sechs Heimspiele in Folge verloren und in allen Spielen kein Tor erzielt. Das gab es noch nie in der Premier League. Das ist schon heftig.
In der Premier League generell oder für Leicester in der Premier League?
In der Premier League generell.
Oder Moment, Premier League jetzt oder quasi auch die Vorgänger League? Also seit drei Jahren? Premier League. Ist trotzdem noch heftig, aber ich dachte schon seit 1888, das wäre hart.
Wobei, bis mal nachschauen, aber ich glaube Premier League. Ich glaube Premier League. Ja, es ist schon arg schlimm. So neun Jahre nach der Sensationsmeisterschaft, das ist gefühlt eine Ewigkeit her. Herrscht wirklich eine toxische, depressive Stimmung bei Leicester. Das Team wirkt demoralisiert. Die Fans gehen nach einer halben Stunde aus dem Stadion, jetzt gegen Brentford, da war man 3-0 hinten. Spieler gehen aufeinander los, beim 0-4 sind da zwei Spieler einander geraten. Also es ist schon übel. Selbst der Fanmarsch, der vor diesem Brentford-Spiel, 0-4 war das Ergebnis, organisiert wurde, der war halbherzig, da sind nicht so viele Leute aufgetaucht, wie man dachte. Und ja, die Leute, die da waren, die stellen sich wie viele andere auch die Frage, was ist denn jetzt eigentlich da passiert? Bei dem Fanmarsch ging es jetzt primär darum, dass man wieder mehr Kommunikation, etwas für das lässt da nicht wirklich stand, aber jetzt halt wirklich notwendig wird. Und vor allem viel mehr Transparenz gefordert wird, denn jeder fragt sich, wie kann es sein, dass eine Mannschaft, die so hervorragend geführt wurde, noch vor neun Jahren Meister wurde unter Ranieri, wir hatten es gerade von ihm.
Sorry, ich wollte es gerade, jetzt schmeiß ich es halt rein. Klingt nach einem Club, der ein Claudio Ranieri bräuchte.
Genau, genau. Und da Ranieri lief es ja, ne?
Ab Sommer hat er ja wieder Zeit.
Genau, genau. Wobei, das will er sich wahrscheinlich nicht antun. Also es ist schon übel. Wie kann es sein, dass eine Verein, der so gut geführt wurde, die ganzen Großen, der primärlich so geärgert hat, wirklich jetzt so vor die Hunde geht, mag ich mal fast sagen. Man ist 2023 mit dem siebthöchsten Gehaltsbudget abgestiegen. Das zeigt einem schon so ein bisschen, wie die Transferphilosophie da war, beziehungsweise wie schlecht die Rekrutierung da war. Die größte Kritik erntet dabei John Watkin, der Director of Football. Und das ist so ein bisschen das Problem bei Leicester. Die letzten neun Jahre ging es wirklich bergab und es hat sich rein gar nichts getan an der Vereinsführung. Einziger natürlich der Besitzer, Vichai, ich möchte jetzt den Nachnamen nicht aussprechen, weil ich krieg's nie hin, aber Vichai ist ja 2018 bei einem Helikopterabschluss gestorben, der Vereinsbesitzer von Leicester. Sein Sohn hat ihn dann beerbt in der Funktion. Also bis auf diese Personalie, möchte ich jetzt fast sagen, hat sich nichts getan bei Leicester. Und das ist ja wirklich bei dem Trend-Ding, der der Verein hinlegt, eigentlich katastrophal. Wie gesagt, John Watkin, Director of Football, ist wirklich so die Hauptzielperson der Fans, wenn es um, beziehungsweise der Sündenbock, gegen der fehlenden Strategie. Es gibt nur Verlustgeschäfte, man hat trotzdem Probleme mit dieser Profit and Sustainability Rules der Premier League, also dem Financial Fair Play dort, hat man massive Probleme. Man ist gerade so einem Punktabzug entwischen im Sommer und hat trotzdem so einen schlechten Kader. Deswegen gibt es eben diese Proteste und viele andere Fans der Premier League sagen, naja, warum reagieren die so übertrieben? Ist man nicht ein bisschen verwöhnt, nur weil man einmal die Meisterschaft gewonnen hat, aber das ist nicht der Punkt, die die Fans machen, sich tatsächlich sorgen, dass der Verein in der dritten Liga landet oder noch schlimmer. Und das ist der Grund für diese Proteste, dass man jetzt in der Bedeutungslosigkeit verschwindet, eben weil der Verein so stur an all seinen Strukturen festhält, an den Leuten festhält, die wirklich seit Jahren katastrophale Arbeit machen.
Das klingt wirklich überhaupt nicht gut. Also vorletzter ist Lester aktuell und zur sportlichen Situation kommt ja wirklich das wirtschaftliche mit dazu. Also ich hab leider jetzt vergessen, ich hab's damals im Sommer gelesen, wie man es geschafft hat, irgendwie diesen Punktabzug abzuwenden. Ich glaube, mit Last-Minutes-Transfers und bei dem einen Transfer war noch so die Frage, war er innerhalb der Frist oder außerhalb der Frist? Und da hat man sich dann, glaube ich, geeinigt, ihr wolltet ihn schon verkaufen. Es lag noch quasi an der Gegenseite, dass es nicht unterschrieben war. Und deswegen zählen wir es noch mit rein oder irgendwie so in diese Richtung ging das. Also so eng war das damals. Und da kannst du dir vorstellen, trotz irgendwelcher Fallschirmzahlungen, die du kriegst als Absteiger oder kriegen würdest in die zweite Liga, dass das wirklich sehr eng wird. Was würde denn der Premier League verloren gehen, wenn Lester absteigen würde? Also die jüngere Vergangenheit haben wir ja alle mitbekommen, eben wegen der Sensationsmeisterschaft. Aber davor wird es bei mir zumindest ganz schön neblig. Ich weiß nicht so viel über Lester.
Ja, also ist jetzt nicht, ich sag jetzt mal, ist jetzt nicht der absolute Riesen-Traditionsverein, der der Liga so wehtun würde, wenn er absteigt. Aber es ist trotzdem ein Verein, den man immer ganz gerne in der Liga gesehen hat. Sie sind ja schon 23 abgestiegen. Es ist, ja, wie soll ich es beschreiben? Sie waren eigentlich so ein typischer, ja, so eine graue Maus, sag ich mal, in der Premier League Geschichte, die erst mit diesem Titel mal ordentlich Popularität zugelegt haben. Aber seitdem ging es wie gesagt bergab. Aber man muss halt auch sagen, es ist ziemlich interessant. Gut, Van Nistelhoi ist ja aktuell dort Trainer. Er wird eigentlich intern und extern relativ hoch geschätzt. Und das spricht ja eigentlich schon Wende über den Kader von Leicester City. Van Nistelhoi hätte jetzt, müssen wir mal nachschauen, ich glaube, ja, 11 von 15 Spielen verloren bei einer Torbilanz von 13 zu 33. Das ist schon heftig. Er ist nicht frei von Kritik, muss man dazu sagen. Also er hält relativ stur an seinem System fest, dass er bei PSV Eindhoven auch spielte und es funktioniert einfach nicht. Er macht zwar viele Wechsel, was das Personal angeht, aber an seinem System hält er stur fest und ein oder zwei Personalentscheidungen sind auch suspekt. Buonanotte zum Beispiel ist so wirklich mit der beste Spieler, würde ich mal behaupten bei Leicester. Er kommt eigentlich nur noch von der Bank, ist relativ fraglich. Deswegen, also er ist nicht frei von Kritik, aber wie er selbst sagt, er versucht das Maximum auszuholen und dieser Mannschaft ist einfach nicht permediktauglich. Das muss man einfach so sagen. Und wenn du jetzt das ganze sportlich siehst, würde man die Mannschaft Leicester City, also das, was die Spieler aktuell auf den Platz bringen, natürlich nicht vermissen. Denn wie Southampton auch sind sie einfach nicht permediktauglich. Da ist es egal, was in der Vergangenheit gearbeitet wurde, sie gehören aktuell einfach nicht in die Liga.
Könnt ihr euch noch erinnern, als vor ein paar Monaten es das Gerücht gab, dass Rudi van Nistelrooy zum HSV wechseln könnte als neuer Trainer? Das wirkt auch so viele Monate weg. Und man weiß gar nicht, was man ihm hätte wünschen sollen, jetzt so im Nachhinein. Also es ist ja irgendwie eine sehr zwiespätige Situation. Und dem HSV geht es ja sehr, sehr gut. Das heißt, die sind da, glaube ich, sehr entspannt. Also die Situation bei Leste, sie ist sehr schwierig und wir bleiben in der schlechten Laune. Jetzt schauen wir auf Real Valladolid. Denn da schaut es auch gar nicht gut aus, Nils.
Ja, hatte Chris eben gesagt, nicht Premier League würdig. Dann ist auch Real Valladolid aktuell ziemlich weit unter Erwartung. Die Schießbude der Liga natürlich. Es sind die Mannschaften, die schon, ich glaube, die wenigsten Schüsse abgeben und auch die zweitmeisten kassieren Abschlüsse und dann auch so viel durchlassen. Das ist mittlerweile Chaos geführter Club, wo man später auch noch über den Präsidenten reden können, wo es eigentlich auch ein paar Transfers gab nach ihrem Aufstieg. Auch jetzt im Winter kam er unter einem Grillage aus Hoffenheim, der jetzt auch schon zwei, drei Mal gespielt hat, aber das ist irgendwie keine Mannschaft da auf dem Platz. Auch da gab es letztens auffällige Fan-Proteste. Real Valladolid hat am Wochenende in Bilbao gespielt, ist damit 7 zu 1 unter die Räder geraten und danach gab es dann so eine Fan-Vereinigung der Fan-Clubs aus Valladolid. Die hatten dann öffentlich mit einer Pressemitteilung formuliert vom Wegen, dass die Spieler bitte für die Kosten aufkommen sollen, die den Fans da entstanden sind. Also Geldentschädigungen zahlen. Das war jetzt keine klare Forderung, sondern eher eine Bitte. Dem Fans ging es mehr darum, für Aufmerksamkeit zu sorgen. Das ging auch durch spanische Medien natürlich, um einfach mal zu zeigen, dass da hinter so einem Club, der so schlecht spielt in dieser Saison, dass da auch einige Fans stecken. Von dem her hatten sie damit Erfolg mit der Reichweite. Natürlich gab es kein Geld vom Verein. Der hatte das dann auch schnell gesagt. Ja, nee, machen wir nicht. Ja, aber also das war schon mal da peinlich, wie generell die ganze Saison. Sie sind mit 16 zu 59 Toren. Das ist ein sehr schlechtes Torverhältnis, auch wenn ich glaube, das ist so ein bisschen. Ich glaube, Darmstadt war noch ein bisschen besser, zumindest letztes Jahr. Also, um das mal so ein bisschen zu vergleichen, wie Punkteausbeut ist und Tordifferenz und ja, einfach da nicht gut. Vor einem Jahr war ich noch in La Liga, da war Almeria noch sieglos. Die hatten da auch nur acht Pünktchen, weil du liest jetzt 15 Pünktchen immerhin. Aber wie gesagt, die lassen sich so regelmäßig abschießen mit mal vier, fünf, jetzt sieben Gegentoren, dass du einfach merkst, dass da im Team zu wenig zusammenpasst, dass das ein bisschen eine bunt zusammengestellte Truppe ist, mit Transfers ausgeführt. Zehn liegen jetzt auch im Winter wieder, also da können wir über die Führung reden. Jetzt wird der dritte Trainer kommen oder es gab jetzt eben zwei feste Cheftrainer, einer mal wieder in Argentinien, der noch nie in Europa trainiert hat, auch noch kaum hier gespielt hat, also eigentlich die Gegner gar nicht kennen kann. Der ist jetzt gegangen wieder, Diego Kocka, jetzt aktuell noch ein Interimstrainer. Mal gucken, ob der bis Saisonende macht, der kommt aus von der B-Mannschaft, der Reserve. Aber auch da wird es wahrscheinlich noch einen dritten festen Cheftrainer geben und das ohne große Hoffnung dafür ist, weil es liegt einfach defensiv zu wackelig und offensiv harmlos und nicht zusammengewachsen und so weiter.
Und du hast gesagt, wir müssen noch über den Präsidenten sprechen. Das ist Ronaldo, also der brasilianische Ronaldo. Wir haben es ja auch schon immer mal wieder hier thematisiert in der Legatur. Und durch deine Formulierung habe ich irgendwie den Eindruck, an dem wird es Kritik, ich zitiere Valadolid hoffnungslos auch dank Nullbock Präsident Ronaldo.
Ja, Nullbock Präsident kann man glaube ich zu bezeichnen, wenn ein Präsident sich nie bei dem Club blicken lässt, nie mal bei Spielen dabei ist. Ich glaube, es war im November eine Ligatur, da hatte ich erwähnt, da gab es bei einem Spiel, ich glaube, Valadolid hatte in Girona verloren. Ronaldo ist rauszukommen, der war nebenbei Tennis spielen und dann im Heimspiel. Danach hatten dann die Valadolid-Fans so eine Choreo gemacht mit Tennislein und dann so einen großen Ball tennismäßig in den Heimspiel. Auch da Aufmerksamkeit. Man sieht in La Liga regelmäßig so Protest-Schilder, gelbe Schilder, schwarze Schrift drauf. Das sieht man regelmäßig bei Valencia. Lim Go Home, Peter Lim Go Home. Das sieht man auch im Valadolid immer öfter, Ronaldo Go Home. Und ja, der ist einfach, wie gesagt, scheint da wenig Interesse zu haben an dem Club, den er 2018 übernommen hat oder die meisten Anteile übernommen hat. Seitdem ist Valadolid eine Fahrstuhlmannschaft. Diesmal ein Jahr wieder erste Liga, dann wieder zurück, dann geht es direkt wieder hoch, aber da gar keine Konstanz. Und dass er auch nicht unbedingt viel Lust hat, mehr auf den Verein, merkt man auch daran mit seinen anderen Zielen und Ambitionen. Der will ja der Präsident vom Brasilianischen Verband werden, also dem Nationalmannschaftsverband in Brasilien hatte da letztens auch eine Meldung von wegen, dass diese Prozesse auch ein bisschen transparenter sind, weil auch da irgendwie einer am Amt ist, der irgendwie die letzten Wahlen immer ohne Gegenkandidat konkurriert hat. Also da Ronaldo ist ganz woanders als da bei seinem Club, dem der vielleicht auch ein paar von bisschen was von seiner Zeit verdient hätte und da eben Fan-Protest riesig und ja, aber irgendwie gibt es nicht so richtige Anstalten, dass es da vielleicht zu einem Wechsel kommt an der Führung, dass Ronaldo vielleicht seine Anteile verkauft, weil wer will so einen KS-Club jetzt aktuell kaufen?
Ich mein, wenn es nicht das ganze Drumherum gäbe, dann könnte man ja auch sagen, schön, dass er sich aus dem Sportlichen raushält und nicht sagt, ich bin der große Ronaldo, ich verpflichte hier sowohl Spieler als auch Trainer, aber das kann man natürlich nicht aus dem Kontext lösen. Warum hat denn Ronaldo überhaupt sich bei Valadolid engagiert? Welche Vorgeschichte kenne ich da nicht?
Eine Vorgeschichte oder Verbindung, dass er mal oder wer auch immer da mal gespielt hat, gab es jetzt nicht. Es ist einfach ein Club so ein bisschen aus der Nähe von Madrid, zumindest anderthalb Zugstunden entfernt und die waren damals vielleicht günstig zu kriegen. Und in seiner langfristigen Strategie hatte sich ja auch noch einen brasilianischen Verein gesichert.
Stimmt, der wollte sein eigenes Multiclub Ownership Ding durchziehen.
Ja, das liegt jetzt mehr nahe, als dass er sich sportlich an dem Verein interessiert hat. Und auch da schon teilweise nicht unbedingt fanaffin Entscheidungen getroffen. Und das Logo wurde auch mal geändert zu so einem modernen Flat Design, Minimalistic Design Logo. Aber da haben auch dann Fan-Proteste dafür geführt, dass wieder das alte Logo eingeführt wurde. Also was Ronaldo macht, ist auch einfach nicht unbedingt Fan. Stößt da nicht irgendwie auf Gegenliebe. Aber wie gesagt, ich glaube, er hatte da primär wirtschaftliche Interessen, sich irgendwie ein Netzwerk vielleicht aufzubauen. Und jetzt ist er dabei, das mehr und mehr vielleicht loszuwerden, abzustoßen, um dann irgendwie noch nach was Höherem zu greifen, wie der Präsidentschaft in Brasilien, also der Fußballpräsidentschaft. Wer weiß.
Da kann man sehr gut nebenher verdienen. Wenn ihr euch fragt, wie lest das Buch zur FIFA von Thomas Gisne, da wird das sehr schön herausgearbeitet. Meine Güte, kann man da reich werden. Ohne das, ohne, naja, egal. Will da jetzt nicht zu tief reingehen. Das wird ja auch alles jetzt ganz anders sein. Inzwischen gibt es ja keine Korruption mehr. FIFA ist ja ein Top-Laden inzwischen. Da sind wir alle sehr dankbar für. So, ein letztes Mal noch nach Italien. Christian, was ist noch zu besprechen? Chris, glaube ich, hat vorhin mal einen Begriff Last Dance gebracht, oder? Das war ja bei Liverpool und Klopp. Oder dann greife ich den doch mal auf und lande kurz bei Atalanta. Gasparini hat vor dem vorletzten oder am letzten Spieltag so eigentlich fast den Nebensatz falden lassen, aber der hat dann für FIFA Ruhe gesorgt, dass er seinen Vertrag im Bergobere nicht verlängern wird und sein Vertrag läuft noch bis 2026, muss man sagen. Also nicht Ende dieser Saison, sondern schon die darauffolgende. Aber es ist halt schon auch dann die Frage, ob vielleicht nicht dann auch womöglich jetzt schon im Sommer Schluss ist. Und dementsprechend ist das gerade eine ziemlich spannende Gemengelage. Atalanta ja auch einer der, also die Thalena hatten ja diesen schwarzen Dienstag und Mittwoch in der Champions League, wo neben Juve eben auch Milan und Atalanta raus ist. Atalanta würde ich ein bisschen in Klammer setzen, weil die hat es wirklich von der Art und Weise erwischt, wie es dir halt in der Champions League in ein Hin- und Rückspiel gehen kann, wenn dir ein bisschen die Szene nicht in deine Richtung laufen. Also die Geschichte war ja 1-1 im Hinspiel gegen Brügge, Rückspiel, erste dominante Hälfte, sie lassen drei Konter zu, es steht 3-0 für Brügge. Die hätten sie logisch auch nicht zulassen dürfen, ist schon klar. Dann machen sie es 1-3, hatten auch schon in der ersten Hälfte Riesenchancen, machen es 1-3, bekommen 11 Meter in der 64. Und wenn sie das 2-3 machen, dann würde ich mal sagen, dann brennt das Ding noch 25 Minuten. Aber Luckmann verschießt ihn, Luckmann kam zur Halbzeit rein, hat das 1-3 gemacht, war nicht der destinierte Elfmeterschütze und da kommen wir auch zu einer kleinen aktuellen Geschichte, deswegen passt das auch wunderbar. Nach dem Spiel, logisch alle gepostet bei Atalanta, ich glaube Atalanta hatten Expected Goals von 3,8 in dem Spiel. Also Brügge kam nicht mehr raus in der zweiten Hälfte. Also es war wirklich bitter aus Atalanta, dass die so rausgegangen sind. Und nach dem Spiel im Frust stellt sich Gasperini hin und sagt, ja gut, Lukman war nicht der destinierte Elfmeterschütze, so gut, so weit, so gut. Und dann kommt aber der Nachsatz, schade, dass er ihn geschossen hat, er ist der schlechteste Elfmeterschütze, den ich jemals gesehen habe. Und der Satz kam überraschenderweise nicht gut an. Da hat sich Lukman logischerweise, finde ich auch völlig zurecht am nächsten Tag, dann selbst zu Wort gemeint, weiß er nicht, was er damit anfangen soll, sehr hart getroffen fühlt er sich halt. Und das war logisch nicht klug von Gasperini, müssen wir gar nicht darüber reden. Gasperini ist halt auch ein sehr straighter Typ, aber mit all seiner Erfahrung. Also den Satz hätte er logisch gerne in den vier Wänden, von mir aus auch in der Kabine sagen können. Von mir aus auch Lukman ins Gesicht, aber halt nicht in eine Fernsehkamera. Also ich glaube, da sind wir uns alle darüber einig. Und dann war halt eben die Frage, ja wie ist jetzt dieses Verhältnis? Wie kriegen Sie das hin? Und die Antwort war jetzt erst mal am Wochenende 5-0-Sieg gegen Empoli Lukman, zwei Puden. Also ich glaube jetzt nicht, dass dieses, auch wenn das Verhältnis zwischen denen jetzt sicherlich nicht komplett ausgeräumt ist, aber ich glaube nicht, dass Atalanta das im Weg stehen wird. Ich glaube, die sind schon alle professionell genug, das gut über die Bühne zu bringen. Und jetzt kommen wir halt zu einem bisschen positiveren Teil, denn Atalanta ist halt auch wieder mitten drin eben im Rennen um den Titel, denn sie sind nur noch drei Punkte von Inter entfernt, nur noch zwei Punkte hinter Napoli. Am Samstag übrigens, 18 Uhr, kann ich nur ans Herz legen, Napoli gegen Inter, das wird 1 gegen 2, Conte gegen Insagi und Atalanta, die halt wieder mitten drin sind. Und dementsprechend deswegen wollte ich das mit Les Stans halt eben aufgreifen. Vielleicht hat das ja auch so eine Energie freigesetzt, dass jetzt bei Atalanta halt alle wissen, okay, es ist klar, die Zeit von Gasperini neigt sich jetzt im Ende zu, wird sich dann zeigen, ob im Sommer oder doch ein Jahr später. Und vielleicht ist jetzt da halt so ein spezielles, wird so ein kleines Ambiente kreiert, wo du halt da jetzt vielleicht noch zwei, drei Prozent mehr rauskitteln kannst, um halt wirklich das zu erreichen, was sehr vor Jahren noch unvorstellbar war. Also ich glaube, wir wären uns alle einig, sollte Atalanta Meister werden, ja, glaube ich, dann haben wir wieder eine besondere Geschichte, würde ich sagen, im europäischen Fußball. Und dementsprechend, ja, bin ich jetzt sehr gespannt, wie sie das hinkriegen. Sie haben jetzt auch nur noch die Liga, also haben jetzt auch nichts mehr mit Doppelbelastung, sind auch in der Coppa Italia raus, können jetzt wirklich auch wie Napoli, Sonntag bis Sonntag mit ihrer Intensität, die wir gewohnt sind. Lukman ist wieder da, der hat ihnen extrem gefehlt, hat eben auch, die hatten jetzt echt Verletzungsbecher auch in diesen entscheidenden Spielen in der Champions League. Da kommen wieder einige zurück. Und ja, ich bin sehr gespannt, ob Atalanta, ob es vielleicht Casperini deswegen vielleicht auch bewusst so gesetzt hat, um da vielleicht auch eine kleine Zusatzenergie freizusetzen, um diesen unfassbaren Traum womöglich wahr werden zu lassen. Das wäre wirklich krass. Also wir schauen uns auf jeden Fall Napoli gegen Inter an, jetzt am Samstag. Und dann Mitte März wird dann auch Atalanta zu Hause gegen Inter spielen. Genau, es kommt auch noch Atalanta Juve. Also das muss ich dazu sagen, vom Spielplan her hat Atalanta mit Abstand das schwierigste Programm der drei da ganz vorne. Also Atalanta hat eben noch Juve, hat noch Lazio auswärts, Bologna auswärts, Milan auswärts. Also vom Programm her sind sie ganz sicherlich nicht die, die da am höchsten anzusehen sind. Aber wir alle kennen Atalanta. Atalanta ist halt auch fähig, mal eine Serie zu starten, dann ist denen relativ egal, gegen wen die spielen. Also deswegen, ich finde es schon sehr charmant, dass Atalanta dadurch, auch dass Napoli und Inter zuletzt eben immer wieder mal Punkte haben liegen lassen, dass sie da wieder dran sind und mal schauen, ob Gasperini mit diesem Last Dance Move vielleicht ein bisschen was freigesetzt hat. Was heißt denn Last Dance auf Italienisch? Ich traue es mir nicht, Christian. Ultimo ballo. Stimmt, eigentlich gar nicht so schwierig. Meine Güte, da stand ich ganz schön auf dem Schlauch. Okay, der Ultimo.
Das hat Titelmaterial. Ultimo ballo.
Ja, das checkt dann wieder keiner. Der ultimative Ball. Muss sich ja um den letzten Ball handeln, oder? Genau, der letzte Ball ist immer der schwerste. Das sagen ganz, ganz viele Teams, wenn sie im Angriffstrittel angekommen sind. Aber ein Grund dafür, warum sie es manchmal sagen, ist, bisschen weirde Überleitung, ist Maxence Lacroix. Ja, wir sind jetzt bei Chris Tepeles gelandet, denn gegen ihn ist der letzte Ball wirklich auf der letzte Wahl, denn Lacroix hatte ihn wieder. Chris, du möchtest ihn mal kurz hier aufs Podest heben, weil er sehr stark spielt gerade.
Ja, ich muss erst sagen Respekt. Ich hab nicht gedacht, dass die Überleitung, also ich wusste nicht, wie du die Überleitung machen willst, aber gut. Ist dir gelungen.
Herzlich willkommen in der Liga Tour. Da wissen alle eigentlich nicht mehr so richtig, wo ich gerade hin will.
Ja, Maxence Lacroix ist wirklich einer der besten Spieler der letzten Wochen in der Premier League. Ich würde jetzt das Chris machen, aber macht keinen Sinn, weil ihr schon wisst, dass es um Crystal Palace geht, aber Crystal Palace hat nach Liverpool in den letzten sieben Spielen die meisten Punkte geholt. Also sehr formstark, fünf der letzten sieben gewonnen, vier davon zu Null. Und das hat natürlich auch mit Lacroix zu tun, der in der Dreierkette von Oliver Glasner im Zentrum spielt. Im Sommer, als er verpflichtet wurde, war man noch so ein bisschen kritisch. Das lag vor allem daran, dass er auch im Anderson verkauft wurde, der eigentlich so der Abwehrchef war der letzten Jahre bei Fulham, wurde aber für 30 Millionen verkauft. Bei Crystal Palace wurde 30 Millionen an Fulham verkauft und Lacroix wurde für knapp 20 geholt. Und jetzt weiß man auch wieso, hat ein paar Anfangsprobleme gehabt. Aber ich meine, wir alle kennen auch seine Qualitäten aus der Bundesliga, unglaublich schnell, physisch stark, kopfballstark, wirkt jetzt auch immer souveräner und selbst wenn er einen Fehler macht oder einen Stellungsfehler macht, dann ist seine Schnelligkeit einfach wieder da, der Schlüssel gegen vollem jetzt zuletzt absolut herausragend, eine tolle Rettungstat gegen Krimines, wer sich sowas anschauen möchte und auf Abwehrszenen steht, ich finde es immer ganz spannend. Dazu auch sehr anticipationsstark, der ist bei Taclins im 94. Perzentilen der Premier League Unterverteidigern, bei Interceptions, also abgefangenen Bällen, 92. Also super Werte. Hat jetzt auch einen Sonderlob von Oliver Glasner bekommen, hat gesagt, dass er auch ein fantastischer Führungsspieler geworden ist und er hat gesagt, dass manche Spieler führen mit ihren Worten, manche mit ihren Aktionen und die Besten machen beides. Und das war das Lob für Lacroix. Und ja, man muss halt echt sagen, für knapp 20 Millionen Euro, da darf man sich jetzt mittlerweile fragen, warum hatten denn nicht andere Kaliber auf dem Zettel? Weil das ist für Premier League Verhältnisse, für so ein Profil schon relativ günstig. Und ich kann mir vorstellen, dass es dann Sommer vielleicht die eine oder andere Anfrage geben wird.
Weißt du, wie ich mitbekommen habe, dass Lacroix offenbar ganz gut spielt gerade bei Crystal, weil ich seinen Namen im Zusammenhang mit Virgil van Dijk gehört habe und eben dem auslaufenden Vertrag, was da dran ist und so weiter, keine Ahnung. Das war in irgendeiner, weiß gar gar nicht, könnte auch auf Blue Sky gewesen sein. Aber da dachte ich mir so, okay, wäre nicht mein erster Gedanke gewesen, ich glaube bei dem läuft es gerade. Dann kam dein Themenvorschlag jetzt ein paar Tage später, da dachte ich mir, okay, gut, hiermit ist es bestätigt. Maxence Lacroix, bei dem läuft es ganz gut. Aber noch ganz kurz die Situation insgesamt bei Crystal Palace. Also es hat sich jetzt wieder ein bisschen stabilisiert. Es war so Tabellen, man ist ins untere Drittel abgerutscht. Jetzt ist man wieder im grauen Mausbereich. Ist das letztlich auch dann okay, gemessen an dem, was der Verein haben möchte? Ich meine, wir haben ja über Crystal auch schon mal gesprochen in dieser Saison. Da lief es noch ein bisschen schlechter. Also wie würdest du so allgemein die Lage des Vereins einschätzen?
Also gerade wenn man sich den Saisonstart anschaut, dürfte man jetzt wirklich absolut zufrieden sein. Vor allem, wenn man bedenkt 36 Punkte nach 27 Spielen, das ist tatsächlich der beste Punktestand in der Premier League Geschichte des Klubs nach 27 Spielen.
Krass. Okay.
Von daher dürfte man relativ zufrieden sein. Letzten Wochen hat auch wirklich die Offensive auch gut nachgelegt. Man hat so das Gefühl, dass Oliver Glasner so ein bisschen die Offensivspieler etwas von den taktischen Zwenken befreit hat. Ist alles ein bisschen frei fließender, ein bisschen kreativer. Aziz ist natürlich auch vorzuweben im offensiven Mittelfeld. Saar hat jetzt zweimal getroffen. In Ketja von Arsenal kommen im Sommer hat jetzt ein erstes Premier League Tor gemacht. Als Stürmer ist das natürlich nicht ein berauschender Wert, aber es scheint ja jetzt in die richtige Richtung zu gehen. Also man dürfte bei Crystal Palace relativ zufrieden mit deinem Entwicklung sein.
Kein Wunder, dass man einen 100 Millionen Euro Preistil auf Oli Glasner draufgepackt hat, als der FC Bayern seine Fessin lösen lassen wollte. Ja ja, interessant, wie das doch so alles verläuft und wie irgendwie alle Geschichten, die wir hier so im Laufe der Jahre besprechen, immer wieder sich miteinander verstricken. Nies, jetzt wollen wir nochmal in La Liga blicken und wir haben vorhin schon mal das Thema Salary Cap gestreift. Jetzt wird es richtig aktuell. Ja ja, wir haben darüber gesprochen bei der finanziellen Situation von Liverpool. Und jetzt wird es aber richtig heftig, denn Sevilla hat es erwischt.
Sevilla hat es auch vorher schon erwischt. Also erst mal noch generell, La Liga versucht jetzt seit fünf Jahren Gehaltsobergrenzen nicht nur zu zeigen, sondern auch durchzusetzen. Das ist jetzt nicht immer gelungen. Auch Basel wurde ja mal auf 200 Millionen runtergestufen. Das ist halt immer so nach den Transferphasen im Spätsommer. Jetzt im Spätwinter, Februar letztens wieder, wurden da diese Gehaltsobergrenzen angepasst. Das sind die Gehälter im gesamten Club, also auch für Trainer und Jugendmannschaften und normale Mitarbeiter. Also Manchester United wär da direkt raus oder würde da noch mehr streichen wahrscheinlich. Es geht auch darum, nicht nur fixe Gehälter, sondern auch variable Gehälter und Kosten mit reinzunehmen. Und da gibt es halt jetzt an sich nicht so viele große Veränderungen. Reamatritis weiter mit 754 Millionen kann am meisten ausgeben. Basel wird hochgeschuft von 426 auf 463 Millionen Euro. Ja und dann gab es schon in der letzten Anpassung im Herbst einfach einen Verein, der nur 2,5 Millionen Euro ausgeben durfte an Gehältern im gesamten Verein. Wie soll das schon mal möglich sein? Hat man sich gedacht, okay vielleicht gibt es da Konsequenzen, weil dieser Verein wird bestimmt drüber sein. Das war da schon der FC Sevilla und jetzt nach dem Winter Transfermarkt, wo der Sevilla auch Jesus Navas Karriereende montiert nach Argentinen verkauft, davor kam auch Vargas aus Augsburg. Jetzt wurde dieser Club noch mal runtergestuft auf 684.000 Euro, was ein kompletter Verein an Gehältern ausgeben darf. Wie soll das möglich sein? Also jetzt redet man nicht darüber, dass es natürlich unmöglich ist, da irgendwie diese Zahlen einzuhalten. Jetzt redet man darüber, dass dieses Salary Cap so gut ich den Ansatz, das Konzept auch finde, finanzielle Fairplay, ein bisschen transparente Zahlen, Clubs sollen nicht mehr ausgeben als sie einnehmen. Finde ich an sich gut den Ansatz, aber jetzt gibt es da jetzt mal Konsequenzen, weil der FC Sevilla, wage ich mal die Vermutung, dass er schon bei den zweieinhalb Millionen Euro der Grenze drüber lag und jetzt bei 684.000 Euro auch da vielleicht mehr Ausgaben hat an Gehältern. Also da macht sich La Liga vielleicht ein bisschen lächerlich mittlerweile, wenn es jetzt keine Konsequenzen gibt.
Moment mal. Also wir hatten das ja schon thematisiert, als es die zweieinhalb Millionen waren. Weil da gab es ja schon die Geschichten, rein theoretisch müssten die jetzt selbst wenn die immer zum Bus anreisen und nur noch die Spieler mitnehmen, selbst dann würden sie schon irgendwie über zweieinhalb Millionen landen. Da gab es so Modellrechnungen mit Hotelkosten und so weiter und so fort. Und wir wissen ja, dass bisher die Sanktionsmöglichkeit war, du darfst dann Spieler nicht registrieren, bis du nicht eben nachweisen kannst, dass du das gegenfinanzieren kannst. Wie ist denn das jetzt bei Sevilla? Also warum werden die nicht sanktioniert oder wie werden sie sanktioniert?
Ja, ist ein gutes Rätsel, was ich auch noch nicht rausfinden konnte. Wie gesagt, war ja auch schon mit den 200 Millionen, gab es da jetzt auch noch keine Konsequenzen. Oder als Baas ja mal auf 200 Millionen runtergesetzt wurde. Auch die konnten dann hier und da noch mal Jorah Felix registrieren oder auch ein Gabi. Darum soll es jetzt hier nicht gehen. Wirklich, es geht auch darum, zum Beispiel, Espanol ist auch eine Mannschaft mit nur einem Budget von 7,8 Millionen Euro. Auch das, ich meine, das nehmen ja, nehmen dir zehn Spiele aus dem Kader und da ist das Budget dann schon voll und 684.000 Euro. Das zahlst du ja schon an Gagen für deine Liga-Tour-Experten quasi. Das ist ja, also wie, das fehlt ja völlig die Praxis, der realistische Bezug in der Umsetzung, weil ja, Sevilla hat finanzielle Probleme und musste auch deswegen in den letzten Phasen immer mal ein paar Spiele so in Fernando noch abgeben. Rakitic musste schnell wieder weg als Kapitän. Navas jetzt Karriereende, auch wenn er eh schon leicht verletzt war, von dem das war geplant. Aber es sieht halt nicht danach aus, als würde es da jetzt in irgendeiner Art und Weise Konsequenzen geben, weil natürlich konnte Sevilla auch einen Vargas registrieren. Und also das ist jetzt das, was ich meine, La Liga macht sich da mehr und mehr lächerlich. So gut der Ansatz auch ist mit Celery Cap einzuführen, aber wenn da Vereine dann trotzdem irgendwie ständig drüber liegen, und wir reden ja nicht nur, dass Sevilla so knapp jetzt noch zwei Millionen Geld hat, sondern normale Vereine hat ja trotzdem irgendwie an seine 100 Millionen Geld oder was auch immer im gesamten Club. Das wird ja scheinbar dann trotzdem jetzt keine Konsequenzen haben wie Punktabzug, Zwangsabstieg, was auch immer, ohne dass ich mir das wünsche für den FC Sevilla. Aber wenn La Liga schon so transparent und in Zahlen veröffentlicht.
Aber das heißt quasi, im Celery Cap ist auch gar nicht festgehalten, was eben passiert, im Falle, dass jemand das wiederholt, sich nicht dran hält.
Nicht wirklich. La Liga versucht zumindest hier und da in seinen Pressemitteilungen immer zu nennen, was alles dazugehört, hatte ich ja genannt, auch die Mitarbeiterkosten und auch die variable Gehälter, aber ohne genaue Konsequenzen. Also sie sagen, guck mal, du darfst nicht mehr ausgeben, du, du, du. Aber Sevilla lag schon über den zweieinhalb Millionen und Sevilla wird auch über den 684.000 liegen. So wie Barca auch über den 200 Millionen lag vor zwei Jahren. Von dem her ist das ja ein bisschen eine Fass geworden, dieses Celery Cap, aber immer wieder, jedes halbe Jahr vielleicht nett ist, hier mal in der Liga-Tour zu erwähnen, hören, Hörerinnen hören, was da teilweise krumme Sachen laufen in der Liga.
Absolut. Und generell muss man sagen, eigentlich ist ja dieser Schritt der Transparenz gut. Also ich fände es gut, wenn wir ähnlich wie im US-Sport manche Zahl wüssten, die jetzt immer nur so gerüchtet wird. Ist ein bisschen schwieriger mit EU-Arbeitsrecht, Datenschutz und so weiter und auch Privatsphäre. Also man kann das auch kritisieren, wie es im US-Sport ist, dass man da quasi bis auf den Dollar Cent runterrechnen kann, wer was wann bekommt und so weiter und so fort. Aber ein bisschen einfacher wird es für uns dann machen, manche Dinge zu verstehen, glaube ich. Weil so wird immer geraunt im Hintergrund. Und das wäre eigentlich zu begrüßen, damit Transparenz zu haben. Ein Stück weit ist das ja in der Liga so. Also gut geht es im FC Sewea nicht. Das wusste man aber schon vorher. Die haben durch die Europa League Gewinne relativ oft ihr wirtschaftliches Ergebnis verbessert und hatten vor allem auf der Transfereinnahmenseite viel zu wenig Ertrag über die letzten fünf Jahre hinweg. Das war eben früher das, was sie so ein bisschen durchfinanziert hat, war eine wichtige Säule beim FC Sewea und das hat dann immer mal wieder gefehlt. Und dann kamen sie schon nach Corona, hätten sie schon eigentlich auch nach UEFA-Richtlinien sanktioniert werden können. Aber sie kamen noch mit der Corona-Ausnahmeregelung durch und haben es dann in der darauffolgenden Saison geschafft. Ich glaube, da haben sie dann wieder Europa League gewonnen oder irgendwie so. Müsste ich jetzt noch mal nachgucken, aber die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist relativ hoch, dass es so war. Und dann sind sie damit dann wieder quasi da rausgekommen. Aber da hatte sie quasi die UEFA auf ihrer Beobachtungsliste, aber eben noch nicht auf der Sanktionsliste. Naja, tja.
Mehr Antworten kann ich euch da auch nicht so geben. Aber vielleicht gibt es in zwei Monaten dann so, jetzt ist doch Punktabzug für Sevier, irgendeine Konsequenz einfach mal, um zu sagen, ja, ihr habt doch mehr ausgegeben als 86.000 Euro.
Ja, ich weiß es nicht. Also ich habe in meiner Verzweiflung per Plexity gerade noch gefragt, also die künstliche Intelligenz, warum werden die nicht sanktioniert? Und hier wird viel einfach nur aufgelistet und am Schluss steht, es ist wichtig zu beachten, dass Sanktionen nicht immer in Form von Punktabzügen oder Geldstrafen erfolgen müssen. Die auferlegten finanziellen Beschränkungen sind bereits eine Form der Sanktionierung, die darauf abzieht, den Verein zu einer verantwortungsvolleren Finanzführung zu zwingen. Und wenn das die künstliche Intelligenz so formuliert, dann müsste ich jetzt noch irgendwie zweimal prompten, um die Quelle zu finden, wo er das rauskopiert hat. Wahrscheinlich steht das irgendwo im Kleingedruckten beim Financial Fair Play von Laliga mit drin. Oder es ist komplett ausgedacht. Darf man auch, kann natürlich auch sein. Aber deswegen habe ich ja meine natürlichen Intelligenzen hier. Heute waren es drei. Ich danke sehr Christian Bernhard. Sorry, Max, darf ich? Bitte, ganz kurz. Ich hatte einen ganz, ganz kurzen Rausschmeißer, nur für Fußballromantiker. Na komm. Ganz kurz, den muss ich noch unterbringen. Pippo Insagi, sagt wahrscheinlich hoffentlich noch ein paar Menschen was. Der mittlerweile nicht mehr so erfolgreiche Insagi-Brüder, wenn es um die Trainerkarriere geht, ist Trainer in Pisa, ist Zweiter in der Serie B, also ist auf dem besten Weg in die Serie A aufzusteigen. Und die, wie ich finde, schöne Geschichte, die wollte ich jetzt einfach noch kurz reinbringen, hat vor kurzem auf die Bank zum ersten Mal einen jungen Herrn, 17 Jahre Jung namens Luis Buffon mitgenommen. Jetzt könnt ihr euch wahrscheinlich denken, was die Vorgeschichte zu Herrn Buffon ist. Ja, Gigi Buffon ist sein Papa. Das wollte ich einfach unterbringen, wenn der Trainer Pipo Insagi, den 17jährigen Sohn von Gigi Buffon, ist übrigens ein Offensivspieler, durfte zum ersten Mal mit bei den Profis. Und ist auch schön, Buffon, der ja mittlerweile eine offizielle Rolle im italienischen Verband in der Nationalmannschaft hat, hat an der Tage auch gesagt, der Junge, er will nicht das Gefühl haben, dass er da irgendwelche Abkürzungen hat wegen seines Namens, deswegen spielt er für die U18 von Tschechien. Dann seine Mutter ist Tschechien und ja, wie gesagt, fand ich sehr nett, Pippo und Sage mit Louis Buffon. Ja, doch noch was für Fußballromantik. Ja, wir werden wirklich alt, ja. Das hört sich an wie ein Doppelsex-Freude. Ja, ist richtig. Ja, aber wirklich. Und gleichzeitig natürlich lustig mit welcher abgeklärt hat dann Buffon, die Familie Buffon dieses mögliche Thema, das ja noch gar keins ist, angeht. Wenn wir drüber nachdenken, könnt ihr euch noch erinnern, wie groß die Aufregung englischer Boulevard-Medien war, ob der Sohn von Harry Kane in Deutschland auf deutschen Boden zur Welt kommt. Großes Thema, ja. Man nimmt einen leichten Unterschied wahr. Also sehr schöner Rausmeister, vielen Dank. Ich danke euch dreien sehr, sehr herzlich Christian Bernhard Nieskern und Chris McCarff. Wie schön, dass du mit dabei bist, Chris. Hat große Freude gemacht mit euch dreien. Danke euch. Danke auch. Danke schön. Und ich danke natürlich auch euch, lieben Hörerinnen und Hörer, denn ihr wisst ja, die 100.000 an Euro, die wir an Gästehornoraren zahlen, die kommen von euch, denn alles, was wir hier machen, ist paywall, Werbe und Sponsoren frei. Und in dieser Folge möchte ich mich bedanken bei Andi, bei Herrn Mosbach, liebe Grüße bei Tobi aus Freiburg, bei Taktik-Tafel F172, der jede Form von Halbfeld-Flanken liebt. Okay, also er ist ein pervers Link. Nein, vielen Dank, schön, dass du da bist. Es gibt sehr, sehr schöne Halbfeld-Flanken. Und Kovie Bryant hat uns auch unterstützt in der jüngeren Vergangenheit. Herzlichen Dank dafür auf rasenfunk.de/supportersclub. Da erfahrt ihr, wie man uns unterstützen kann. Geht mit einem Betrag eurer Wahl und in der Höhe eurer Wahl. Und im Grunde habt ihr eigentlich auch die freie Zahlungsmittel-Methodenwahl. rasenfunk.de einfach auf den Unterstützen-Button klicken. Ganz herzlichen Dank an alle, die es getan haben. Und abonniert doch auch sehr gerne unsere anderen Feats. Wir machen Sendung zur Bundesliga der Männer, zur Bundesliga der Frauen. Gerade ist eine Folge zu den letzten beiden Länderspielen der Frauen erschienen im Nationalteams-Feed. Und es gibt noch den Trembüngen-Gespräch-Feed. Da haben wir über das Polizeikosten-Urteil des BGH kürzlich gesprochen. In diesem Sinne bleibt gesund. Bis bald.
Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen. Vielen Dank.